Gerade wenn du jetzt irgendwie die Videos schaust, die so im Netz rumschwören, wo Leute irgendwie, die einen Vakuum haben, irgendwie auch so ein iPad Pro gekauft haben und den Pencil, was die so im Vergleich irgendwie sagen, das ist, das ist alles schon sehr, sehr, sehr positiv für das Pro mit dem Pencil zusammen.
Und dann habe ich Notes probiert, also Notizen, und war total geflasht, weil das, was ich da gemacht habe, war halt einfach, sah aus wie mit einem Bleistift gezeichnet. Und es fühlte sich auch an wie mit einem Bleistift zeichnen.
Das Beispiel mit Lua war aber jetzt eben gerade mit...
Das ist genau so was. Das ist genau so ein Software Defined Networking System, was auf der CPU läuft, auf einer Stock-CPU mit Standard-Billig-Ethernet-Karten, wo dann eben kein FPGA mehr benötigt wird. Insofern ist FPGA immer so ein bisschen Spezialaufgabe und hat im Wesentlichen so einen intellektuellen Charme.
Und ein Switch hat eine gewisse Logik. Die ist simpel, aber er hat schon eine gewisse Logik.
Im Gegensatz zu?
einem Hub.
Ja, richtig.
Ein Hub war so in ein Loch rein, aus innen Löchern raus. So, egal wie, wann, warum. Und ein Switch denkt darüber nochmal kurz vorher nach, was er wo lang schickt.
Ja, das ist schon... Ich meine, bei Cisco hat sich das ja auch früher abgezeichnet. Sie ist ja iOS, ne? Heißt das eigentlich immer noch iOS?
Schreibt sie ja mal mit einem großen I.
Hat Cisco nicht auch die Bude, die irgendwas neuerdings Lisp nennt?
Nein, es gibt ein Protokoll, wo Cisco Leute auch mit dran gewurstet haben. Die Idee fand ich mal ganz schick. Ist aber dann wieder mal zerkaut und zerkaut worden, zerstampft worden unter den Wüten von irgendwelchen Normierungsspackos in der ITF und ist also jetzt heutzutage unbrauchbar. Aber hier war es mal total hype, weil dir versprechen war, dass du per Lisp mehrere Links, die du hast, bündeln kannst. Das war der Hoffnungsschimmer am Horizont für die armen Leute, die hier in kleinen Kukakerode mit 768 Kilobit DSL sitzen, die dann gesagt haben, scheiß drauf, ich kaufe mir halt drei von den Dingern, damit ich wenigstens zwei Megabit habe. Nur wie kriege ich sie gebündelt?
Ja, ich meine, synchrone Netze haben auch was für sich. Manche Sachen gehen echt einfach.
Ja, und Lisp, das war das große Versprechen. Aber wie gesagt, nachdem irgendwelche Leute, die da in der Standardisierung tätig sind, haben gesagt, das ist aber ein Feature, das wollen wir für Lisp genau nicht haben. Und alle so, was machst du jetzt sonst damit?
Ja, war auch ein schlechter Name.
Auf jeden Fall.
Außerdem hat es einen immensen Verbrauch an IP-Adressen gehabt. Das kam noch erschwerend hin.
Ein kostbarer IP-Adressen. Ich dachte, das ist kein Problem mehr.
Ja, auf der V6-Seite hat auch kein Hahn danach gekriegt. Aber Lisp kann sowohl V6 als auch V4. Und die V4-Leute waren dann doch eher traurig darüber, dass ein User jetzt plötzlich drei oder mehr IP, V4, Public IP, V4-Adressen verbratzt, statt nur einer.
Ja, wo wollen wir, ihr dürft jetzt auswählen, wollen wir gleich im Networking-Bereich bleiben?
Weil es da gerade so schön ist in diesem Network-Bereich.
Ich weiß nicht, wir können auch über Swift reden.
Ah, hier gibt es das.
Also wir bleiben am Networking-Bereich, wenn du jetzt schon so schön fragst. Scroll mal dahin, wo sind wir?
Da oben sind wir. Ja, es gibt da ja so einiges, was thematisiert worden ist in den letzten zwei Wochen. Nichts, was wir nicht hier auch schon in irgendeiner Form thematisiert hätten. Es gab viel Geschrei um Vectoring. Da geht es wohl irgendwie gerade in die finale Entscheidungsebene.
Oder auch nicht. Nee, nee, nee. Vectoring nicht, sondern Vectoring am Hauptverteiler. Die grundsätzliche Geschichte für Vectoring ist ja schon gefallen. Vielleicht soll ich nochmal kurz erklären, worum es geht. Vectoring ist die geniale Idee einer sterbenden Industrie. Und einer Telekom, wie man das alte, längst überfällig aus dem Boden zu reißende Kupferkabel doch nochmal ein paar Jahre länger benutzen kann. Weil es war ein schönes Geschenk der Steuerbezahler an die Telekom. Und warum soll man das jetzt wegwerfen? Gegen was Vernünftiges. Deswegen versucht man also aus Kupferkabeln immer mehr Bits raus zu wringen. Eine der Methoden dazu ist Vectoring. Wir hatten das auch schon ein paar Mal besprochen. Das erlaubt sozusagen, dadurch, dass man die Störungen, die im Boden nebeneinander liegenden Kupferkabel, die ja ein Übersprechen gibt... Wenn man sich das ausmisst, so ein Netzbad im Boden vergraben, das ist ja relativ statisch. Das ist ja fest montiert und so und wackelt eigentlich nicht so viel rum. Und wenn man das ganze Ding ausmisst, ist das eigentlich nur eine riesentolle, große Antenne mit, keine Ahnung, ein paar hundert Enden. Und wenn man das also weiß und sich das entsprechend ausgemessen hat, kann man seine Signale so modulieren, dass weder was vernünftige dabei rauskommt. Also sozusagen, die Störungen kann man vorhersehen, die durch Crosstalk entstehen und kann die sich sogar nutzen. Damit das funktioniert, müssen aber alle Leitungen, die das betrifft, also alle Leitungen, die aus dem Verteiler rauskommen, unter der Kontrolle eines d-Slam stehen. Sonst hat er ja keine Chance, wenn daneben noch der vom Mitbewerber ist und auch noch mitreinsendet und die nicht miteinander reden, wird das nichts. So, das ist eine tolle Idee. Und aus irgendwelchen unerfindlichen Gründen fandet die Telekom auch total toll, weil sie dann irgendwie sich sagt, naja, das ist aber schade, dass jetzt keine Mitbewerber mehr auf unseren Leitungen rumbasteln können. Worauf den natürlich die erst mal wieder CETA und Morio geschrieben haben. Und so ist es denn gekommen, dass also jetzt schon seit längerem eine Regelung existiert für die Outdoor-Dislamps, also diese Kästen, die auf der Straße stehen, die mit Glasfaser versorgt werden. Und wo dann sozusagen aktives Equipment auf der Straße steht, wird die Häuser versorgt. Da ist es so, da gibt es jetzt inzwischen seit letztem Jahr oder so, gibt es eine Datenbank, die von dem vertrauenswürdigen Unternehmen T-Systems geführt wird, wo alle Leute, die gerne Vectoring anbieten möchten, alle Firmen, denen Kunden sich eintragen können, sich sozusagen an so einem Kasten bewerben können. Und die schwierige ist halt, der, der den Zuschlag kriegt, einen solchen Kasten mit Vectoring versorgen zu können, hat diesen Kasten dann auch exklusiv, muss aber allen anderen Marktteilnehmern auch zu fairen, gleichen Konditionen auch den Zugang dann auf höherer Ebene dazu anbieten. Diese Nummer ist jetzt schon eine Weile rum, die zieht sich immer noch so ein bisschen hin. Man liest jetzt dieser Tage immer auch, die Telekom hätte schon Millionen von solchen Anschlüssen gemacht und so, ich kenne keinen einzigen. Wir haben jetzt so viele Hörer, da gibt es bestimmt welche, die sowas haben, ich kenne keinen einzigen. Es betrifft auch zum Beispiel nicht die Leute, die in der Stadt wohnen in der Regel, weil die normalerweise dicht genug am Hauptverteiler hängen. Das ist jetzt nämlich der neue Teil, wo jetzt seit wenigen Wochen und Monaten nochmal wieder intensiver gekloppt wird. Weil das, was ich eben beschrieben habe, gilt nur für diese externen D-Slams, die draußen auf der Straße stehen. Für alle Sachen, die sozusagen aus dem Hauptverteiler kommen, wurde jetzt immer noch mal hin und her gehandelt. Und machen wir das jetzt oder nicht oder so? Und die Telekom hat einen Antrag gestellt bei der Regelungsbehörde, hat gesagt, wir würden das gerne einfach alles machen. Wir machen jetzt hier unsere 8000 HVWs.
Wann kommt denn das aus dem Hauptverteiler und wann kommt es aus dem D-Slam?
Das hängt davon ab, wie weit du entfernt wohnst von der Vermittlungsschule.
Also es geht sozusagen nur um die Anschlüsse, die so nah am Hauptverteiler sind, dass da nicht nochmal eine andere Box ist.
Aber sind das überhaupt so viele? Ja, das sind reichlich. Die Dinger stehen ja aus traditionellen Gründen. Die traditionellen Standorte für solche Dinger sind gerade im städtischen Bereich, mitten in der Stadt. Weil man konnte ja damals auch das analoge Telefon, die Kupferstrippen, als sie damit angefangen haben, auch nicht so lang machen. Also hast du hier schon in der Stadt schon ein paar Dutzend von denen rumzustehen, die sich ganz gut verteilen.
Und wie weit kann das Kabel laufen für so ein normales DSL, dass man direkt am Hauptverteiler angeschlossen ist?
Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, was die aktuellen, wo sie den Break machen für so einen Outdoor-D-Slam, wo sie sagen, ab wo man so einen Outdoor-D-Slam haben muss. Ja, so in dem großen Ort.
Da ist schon ein gewisses Einzugsgebiet.
Ja, da müsste ich mal nachgucken. Aber wie gesagt, das betrifft durchaus etliche Leute. Und das ist ja auch ein Radius. Also hast du schon größere Cola, die dann da in der Stadt liegen. Ja, und diese Dinger, da hat die Telekom in den Antrag gestellt, gesagt so, wir machen das einfach alles und ja, die armen Mitbewerber kriegen hier auch noch Bits von uns und können dann auch unsere Anschlüsse mitverkaufen und alles wird gut. Und da hat die Bundesnetzagentur gesagt, naja, eigentlich finden wir das ja ganz toll. Komm mal aber! Und kam dann mit total wilden Ideen von, dann soll die Telekom irgendwelche Mitbewerber Geld zahlen für irgendwelche Ausfälle, irgendwelche Verdienstausfälle und was weiß ich nicht alles. Und irgendwelche Mitbewerber dürfen sich vorher auch noch die Rosinen rauspicken. Wo finde ich jetzt, die Telekom wieder einen Rückzieher gemacht hat und gesagt hat, naja, also dann haben wir auch keinen Bock drauf. Also wir versorgen schon alle Dinge, also auch einen kleinen Kuhkakerode und so. Wurdet sich nicht lohnt für uns. Aber dafür wollen wir natürlich auch alle haben, weil dann kann man noch eine schöne, sozusagen eine schöne, wie sagt man, eine Mischkalkulation machen. Wenn er uns aber vorher erinnert, die Rosinen aus dem Kuchen pickt und wir dann einen kleinen Kuhkakerode versorgen sollen, wo wir draufzahlen, dann haben wir doch auch keinen Bock mehr. Also das geht jetzt auch immer noch wieder so hin und her und her und hin, während in anderen Ländern Glas verbuddelt wird, bis der Arzt kommt.
Neulich ging noch irgendwie so Statistiken rum, auf welchen Platz Deutschland mittlerweile angekommen ist, so mit Glasfaserverbreitung. Oder irgendwie eine Zahl im Kopf ist, weil irgendwas schlimm ist.
Ne, das frustriert mich zu sehr. Das ist relativ weit unten.
Also schon so Platz 50 oder so was.
Ich glaube sogar weit hinter Rumänien. Nichts gegen Rumänien, aber so pfff.
Rumänien ist ziemlich gut dabei.
Da fällt die Deutschen immer so auf dicke Hose. Und was mich auch immer wieder irritiert ist, sie müssen es ja dann auch immer so ultimativ machen. Also in Deutschland wird ja gar nicht darüber diskutiert. Oder doch, es wird jetzt gerade mal ganz vorsichtig diskutiert, ob man nicht vielleicht auch mal ein Glasfaserkabel oberirdisch verlegen könnte. Auf dem Land zum Beispiel, an einen Mast. Da muss man jetzt Studien für machen, ob das geht. Man ist natürlich viel zu stolz, um mal nach Frankreich zu fahren oder nach Spanien oder so und sich das anzugucken, wie das geht. Nein, da macht man wieder eigene Studien, ob das in Deutschland möglich ist, auch mal so ausnahmsweise mal so ein Glasfaserkabel an den Mast zu hängen, statt hineinzugrammen. Okay, sieht jetzt, wenn man sich so manche Innenstädte anguckt, in Nachbarländern, die sowas haben, sieht jetzt auch nicht so sexy aus, wenn die ihre Kabelbäume draußen an der Wand dran haben. Nichtsdestotrotz, dass man das bei uns kategorisch ausschließt, ist auch schon wieder ein interessantes Signal.
Das fand ich in Wolgograd so geil. Da hatten nämlich die Hochhäuser die Funktion, so Leitungsverteiler für alle anderen kleineren Häuser außen rum zu sein. Das sah immer so ein bisschen aus, wie ein abgespannter Weihnachtsbaum.
Sieht scheiße aus. Muss man auch nicht so extrem machen.
Lieber Glas auf dem Dach als Rupfer im Boden.
Gibt ihr diese schöne Bild von Stockholm, wie von 1800, oder Anfang 19. Jahrhundert, wo sie auch so zwei Türme haben, wo alle Telefondrähte direkt von da quer über die ganze Stadt gehen?
So ein zentraler Verteiler oder zwei?
Ein zentraler Verteiler und er geht oben über alle Dächer.
Jahrhundert meinst du?
Anfang 20. Jahrhundert, ja, stimmt. Oder Ende 19. Muss man gucken, Stockholm, Telefonverteiler oder so. Ist ein relativ berühmtes Bild. Ja, das ist halt eben schade wieder mal. Und wenn jetzt die Leute schon wieder rummauen und sagen, naja, aber selbst wenn wir jetzt hier mit Vectoring uns einen abbasteln, genau dieses Bild meinte ich.
Sieht aber auch gut aus.
Ich hab aber eben aufs Richtige geklickt.
Hast du da iMessage da auf deinem Rechner, wo ich dir ein Bild schicke, Timme?
Nee, Pinterest führt mich jetzt hier gerade in die falsche Richtung. Ist das der hier, ja, ne?
Das ist immer auf derselben Drecksite. Ja, und nachdem jetzt die Leute wieder rumgemault haben, haben wir gesagt, ja, aber das wegdrücken kann ja auch nicht der Lösung, oder der weiß halt, letzter Schluss sei, dann kommen sie jetzt da, es kommt ja dann auch G-Fast. G-Fast ist jetzt sozusagen... Bitte was? Noch so ein Begriff. Noch so ein Begriff, wo sie sich jetzt überlegt haben, okay, man könnte sogar noch aus dem Kupferdraht vielleicht auch ein Gigabit rausquetschen. Auf eine Handvoll Zentimeter oder so. Also es ist jedenfalls total absurd, wie sie versuchen, da immer mehr rauszumachen. Und das wird immer wieder hochgespült und das ist immer wieder das tolle Mittel der Wahl. Und man hört immer wieder, dass ein Glasfaserausbau unmöglich ist und zu teuer und so weiter und so fort. Man muss echt nur 50 Meter hinter die Grenze fahren. Ja, sieht man, dass das nicht der Fall ist. Und das ist halt so ärgerlich, dass die so... Aber das haben jetzt schon alle...
Aber zum Beispiel in Berlin liegt doch auch überall Glasfaser in...
Hier liegt jede Menge Glasfaser.
Nee, auch. Alle möglichen Provider haben ja auch Glas im Boden. Kriegt man das nicht?
Kannst du eigentlich in jeder deutschen Stadt mal angucken, wenn man mal mit dem Augen auf dem Bürgersteig nach unten guckt, die Deckel, die da rumliegen. Entweder steht da ein Tee drauf oder so was wie Versatel oder Acor oder Colt oder so. Also es gibt durchaus Watt und die Telekom muss ja auch diese Outdoor-D-Slams ja auch mit Watt versorgen. Und es ist wie gesagt auch noch aus der Europa- und Isis-Zeit, also Anfang der 90er, ist ja auch noch jede Menge Zeug da, was man benutzen könnte. Okay, das geht jetzt vielleicht nicht in jedes Haus, aber die Grundinfrastruktur ist ja erstmal da. Das musst du mal den Link nachher mal. Aber das ist wie gesagt schon ein bisschen krass. Ein so ein Turm und dann einfach von da gnadenlos in jedes Haus reingespannt. Also so was wir dann auch nicht haben, aber trotzdem, das muss auch noch einen Mittelweg geben. Ja, aber das meiste davon hatten wir schon mal bloß, wie gesagt, es gibt jetzt Geistert mal wieder durch die Gegend, weil jetzt mal wieder gerade der halt mal wieder hochgespielt wird, seitens Telekom und der anderen. Aber noch bewegt sich nichts. Ich würde mich ja mal freuen, wenn es ja mal Leute gäbe, die sich vielleicht mal melden, die mal wirklich so einen Vectoring-Anschluss haben und dazu mal was erzählen, wo sie den haben und so.
Wie schnell sie gevektort werden?
Ja, also verkauft wird es ja als 100 Megabit im Downlink und 40 im Uplink. Da würde ich gerne mal hören, ob es jemanden gibt, der das wirklich hat.
Im Winter war da einer dauerbeschäftigt zum Eis abklopfen, oder?
Bei den ganzen Kabel?
Ja, wenn es einmal langschnäht, wird es auch richtig schwer. Es skaliert auf jeden Fall nicht gut.
Gut, dass sie das in Stockholm gemacht haben, und nicht in Mexico City. Eben.
Vögel.
Wenn mal einmal so ein Schwarm landet, dann bricht der Turm ein. So, nächste Thema.
Freifunk-Rocks.
Du willst das jetzt aufmachen, oder? Nee, ich hab gestern, war das gestern? Ich hab gestern mehr mal wieder erlaubt, wie ein Freifunk-Hotspot, nein, wie nennt sich das? Ein Freifunk, die nennt das doch nicht Hotspot.
Ja, war doch immer.
So ein Ding da zu kritisieren. Nee, nee, nicht zu kritisieren. Ich hab ihn gelobt, ich hab gesagt, das ist total toll und total frei. Was wird mir erzählt, wie voll frei das ist?
Also dein Tweet war missverständlich. Ich hab das so interpretiert, Freifunk, naja, geht spielen.
Ich hab gesagt, ich habe jetzt hier mal durch Zufall wieder, da bin ich an einem Laden vorbeigelaufen draußen, da hing so ein Schild im Fenster. Hier, Freifunk, offenes, freies WLAN. Die haben da auch richtig so Logo und so, weil das können sie ja. Da haben sie ja jemand, der hat da mal so ein Logo gemacht und druckt auf Kleber und so weiter und so fort. Also so Marketing haben sie sich schon mal ein bisschen mit befasst. So, und dann denkt mir, oh, das ist ja mal toll, das machst du jetzt mal an. Und hab auch tatsächlich eine Adresse gekriegt, und zwar eine Adresse der US Navy. Okay, da kommen wir jetzt zu einer IPv4-Adresse der US Navy. Aber wollen wir nicht so kleinlich sein. V6 habe ich nicht gekriegt, aber okay, man ist ja jetzt 2015. Dann müssen wir uns schon noch ein bisschen Zeit lassen. Hauptsache, das ist frei halt. Und dann habe ich gedacht, oh das ist ja toll, dann machst du mal einen Speedtest. Und dann hat mein Speedtest mir sagenhafte 10 Kilobit im Upload angezeigt.
Brauchst du etwa mehr oder was?
Dann wollte ich das tweeten. Und die 10 Kilobit haben dafür nicht gereicht. Okay, da war jetzt ein Bild noch dran, nämlich dieser Screenshot. Aber das hat nicht geklappt. Dann habe ich halt wieder, nur um den Tweet loszuschicken, habe halt mein LTE kurz, wüsste ich mal, wieder aktiviert, hatte dann temporär meine 35 Megabit im Uplink, habe dann den Tweet abgesetzt und habe mich danach wieder fein über das Freifunkzeugs gefreut. Und da gab es jetzt Leute, die meinten, ich soll das nicht mehr in den Dreck ziehen. Und ich habe das nicht in den Dreck gezogen. Das war total toll. Total freies Internet. Zehn Kilobit. Haben oder nicht haben?
Willst du mein altes Modem haben?
Weil diese Einweichungen sind jetzt noch gar nicht mehr so teuer. Da gab es eben echt Leute, die haben mich wieder angefeindet, wie ich wagen könnte, diese unglaubliche freiwillige Arbeit von Freiwilligen, die sich da bemühen, in den Dreck zu ziehen. Ich habe das nicht in den Dreck gezogen. Aber ich finde, 10 Kilobit fällt bei mir ganz deutlich in den Range von Funktional kaputt. Und freiwillig oder nicht, mein Grundbedürfnis, was zu haben, was funktioniert, steht, glaube ich, da drüber, über dem Lob, dass Leute sich da freiwillig engagieren.
Weil frei funktioniert der Wille.
Einen Hotspot ist jetzt aber auch wirklich mal ein sehr schmales Sample von deiner unvergleichlichen Studie.
Ich muss dazu sagen, ich suche die nicht, aber wenn mir einer begegnet, teste ich ihn nicht. Wenn mir einer begegnet, wenn da so ein Aufkleber ist, teste ich den. Und ich habe in Potsdam jetzt schon 3er getestet, das war in Potsdam. Die sehen alle so aus. Bei M kriegt man zwar eine Adresse und gar keine externe Konnektivität. Und der hatte immerhin 10 Kilobit-Uplink in die große böse Welt.
Aber dieses ganze Wi-Fi, das ist auch nicht dafür geeignet. Eine Infrastruktur, das ist einfach dafür nicht gemacht.
Umso lächerlicher.
Dass man sich irgendwelche billig Plastikbüchsen kauft und die in die Luft hält und dann ist Freitpunkt.
Umso lächerlicher ist es ja auch, wenn der Berliner Senat jetzt wieder ankommt mit seinem Ding. Wir machen jetzt Touri-WLAN wieder total frei. Das kann gar nicht frei sein. Sie schmeißen jetzt irgendwelche, haben aus irgendwelchem Briefmarkenbudget so 170.000 Euro davon, die sie jetzt irgendeiner Firma an Fird in den Rachen schmeißen. Die jetzt in Berlin irgendwelche Access Points hinklatschen, wo irgendwelche Touris sich rumfallen.
Auf der Captive Page musst du dir erst mal eine Minute eine Werbesaitung ansehen, bevor du eine halbe Stunde klicken darfst.
Ganz umsonst wird es nicht sein. Von 170.000 Euro kannst du so ein Ding vielleicht gerade mal aufbauen mit der Hardware. Aber irgendwann musst du es auch noch betreiben. Dann gibt es wieder so Spielchen, ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob es so ist oder so werden wird, aber was kolportiert wurde, ist, dass man dann 30 Minuten frei hat. Aber das ist doch nicht frei. Frei heißt frei. Frei heißt, ich darf, wann ich will, so viel wie ich will, oben, unter, rechts, links, wie ich will.
Frei und kostenlos muss man jetzt mal unterscheiden.
Free, kostenlos, guck nach, was der Senator kolportiert.
Ja, ich habe auch von diesen 30 Minuten gehört. Es ist ja auch klar, dass das...
Aber das ist einfach der falsche Ansatz. Der Regulierer muss ran und muss die LTE-Preise regulieren. Fertig, sodass das bezahlbar ist. Und solange der Regulierer das nicht macht, ist das eben teuer.
Nee, der ist zu tief gegriffen, dieser Ansatz. Wir sollten mal grundsätzlich darüber diskutieren. Das hatten wir hier schon ein paar Mal. Ist das jetzt Infrastruktur oder ist das Markt? Ist das Luxus? Die Entscheidung muss die Politik mal treffen. Sie sagen ja auch, eine Straße ist Infrastruktur. Die bauen wir als Staat. Brauchen dafür irgendein Geld, kostet irgendein Geld. Dann gibt es hier mal Maut und so weiter und so fort. Aber für Straße wird in Deutschland komplett angesehen, das ist Infrastruktur. Wir sind nun mal in Deutschland. Natürlich ist das ein spezielles Ding. Glaubst du, wie ich mich schäme, wenn ich im Ausland bin? Oder gucke, wie die das gebacken kriegen? Und hier bei uns in Deutschland ist Internet aus Sicht der Politik ein Luxusgut für kaputte Hacker, Porn-Surfer, Kriminelle. So wird das angesehen. Und deswegen passiert das auch nicht. Wir brauchen jetzt gar nicht über so tiefe Themen wie LTE-Tarefe zu diskutieren. Sondern wir müssen erstmal grundsätzlich ein Verständnis dafür herstellen, und zwar ein gesellschaftliches und damit vielleicht auch ein politisches. Was ist das? Wollen wir das haben? Wollen wir das alle haben wie eine Straße? Oder wie eine Eisenbahn? Das ist ja auch mal eine Infrastruktur.
Ja Clemens, das ist eben genau der Punkt. Ich finde ja im Prinzip den Ansatz richtig, aber es gibt viele andere Sachen, die dann auch erst mal wieder verstaatlicht werden müssten, bevor man über das Internet redet. Das Internet jetzt dann so als, das ist mir besonders wichtig und das muss als erstes verstaatlicht werden.
Hab ich dir nicht gesagt. Ich halte ja nicht die Freifunk-Fahne hoch. Oder die Internet muss frei und umsonst für alle sein, Fahne.
Ja, aber du sagst, Regulierung sei nicht der richtige Weg. Aber das ist eben der Weg, mit dem die Politik im Moment auf diese Dinge einwirken kann. Also es wird ja alles Mögliche verkauft und privatisiert und der Staat behält sich dann eben vor, durch Regulierungsmaßnahmen zu bestimmen, wie bestimmte Dinge eben zu tarifieren sind. Das gibt es für Strom. Ich weiß nicht, ob es das für Strom überhaupt gibt. Für Infrastruktursachen gibt es das halt in jedem Fall.
Ja, und sie haben halt bisher nicht erkannt, dass das Infrastruktur ist. LTE ist keine Infrastruktur für den Staat. Deswegen wird er auch nicht reguliert. Telefon wird reguliert. Zumindest in gewissen Bahnen, dass du sagst, also hier, die Bundesnetzagentur passt auf, dass jeder jeden anrufen kann, bei egal welchem Provider er ist und dass diese Anschlüsse auch überall bundesweit zur Verfügung stehen. Soweit sind alles Regulierungsmaßnahmen. LTE fällt da nicht drunter.
Du kritisierst doch genau, was ich auch kritisiere. Nämlich, dass der Regulierer sich diese Sache vornehmen muss. Weil das eben der Mechanismus ist, wie in diesem Staatssystem im Moment solche Sachen passieren. Das ist ja richtig. Eigentlich will man das alles verstaatlicht haben. Also jedenfalls, wenn man das politisch so sieht. Aber das sei ja meistens nicht Thema. Weil da müsste man eben auch noch andere Sachen verstaatlichten. Und wenn es nur ums Internet geht, dann finde ich die Forderung danach, dass das Internet besser reguliert wird, das finde ich vernünftig. Aber gut.
Bei den Roaminggebühren europaweit kriegen sie das ja auch irgendwie hin. Dann können sie das ja auch mal machen. Inzwischen ist ja über Europa Zeugtelefon ja billiger als lokal.
Na klar, ist schon länger. Das ist wirklich echter Albern. Na ja, wie gesagt, WLAN ist sowohl technisch nicht die richtige Infrastruktur, um größere Stadtflächen zu versorgen. Ist halt, wie sage ich, ein nettes Goodie. Und dieser Tag ist ja auch wieder diese ganze Zerstörerhaftungsnummer mal wieder unterwegs in der Presse und in der Politik. Und da muss ich auch was tun. Aber es ist wie gesagt kein Allheilmittel. Und wenn ich so was höre, dass Leute irgendwie 600 Access Points in Berlin anschrauben wollen, dann bin ich kaputt.
Bei 3, 3,5 Millionen, wie viele Einwohner sind das dann pro Access Point?
4 Millionen.
Das ist nur für die Touristen.
Das sind ja auch nur 600.
Ja, da könnte man auch den SIM-Card noch einfach frei verkäuflich machen, dann wäre das Problem mit den Touristen auch vom Bein. Ja, aber stattdessen schrauben sie viel an Access Points in die Gegend.
Zu deiner 7-Tage-Touri-Karte könnten sie einfach hinten eine SIM-Karte draufkleben.
Genau, die BVG 24-Stunden-Karte, gleich mit ein bisschen SIM und Zeug dabei.
Ja, Begrüßungsgeld. Genau, 10 GB reicht für ein Wochenende. Da kommt man irgendwie mit hin. Um vielleicht nochmal auch was Positives zu sagen zu dieser Freifunkgeschichte. Also ich denke, dass es da auch innerhalb dieser Freifunk-Community sehr unterschiedliche Wahrnehmungen dessen gibt, was dieses Projekt leisten soll und was es nicht leisten soll. Und wenn man sich anschaut, wo es herkam, nämlich es gibt kein Netz in Friedrichshain, und dann müssen wir jetzt mal sozusagen eine Antenne aufstellen. Das ist ja auch vollkommen in Ordnung. Und ich finde, die haben auch eine ganze Menge geleistet für ebenso Regionen, in denen es halt wirklich total katastrophal ist. Und jetzt zeigt sich das zum Beispiel auch gerade jetzt hier wieder bei den Flüchtlingsnotunterkünften und sonstigen Unterkünften, wo halt einfach auch lange Zeit nirgendwo was passiert ist, wo dann ebenso die Freifunkhorden reinmarschiert sind. Und dann eben auch sowohl das Know-how und auch die Technik am Start hatten, um eben genau diese spezifische lokal begrenzte Problem zu lösen. Das finde ich auch gut. Aber ich stimme euch auch zu. WLAN in den Städten ist Netz dagegen.
Was mich so ein bisschen auch daran nervt, also die Idee finde ich grundsätzlich gut. Und wie du gerade gesagt hast, aus der Anfangszeit, dass das ganze Stadtviertel gab, die nichts ordentliches hatten an Netz, ich bin da voll bei dir, das war eine tolle heroische Tat und so weiter und so fort. Ich finde, jetzt albern hinzugehen und gegen die drölfzig Kabelanbieter, DSL-Anbieter, Glasfaser, LTE-Anbieter, la la la, in der Stadt auch noch antreten zu wollen. Nur mit dem Argument, ja wir sind da so unglaublich frei.
Das macht doch überhaupt keinen Sinn, dieses Argument.
Das kriege ich aber zu hören! Das kriege ich zu hören, das ist das Problem!
Ja, aber doch bestimmt nicht von den Freifunk-Leuten selbst, also das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass die zum Ziel haben, gegen die Kabel- und DSL-Anbieter anzulehnen.
Was ich durchaus okay finde, wenn die jetzt ihre Nano-Stations zu viel haben, die rumzulegen haben, ich habe übrigens auch noch ein paar davon, die ich auch noch vergeben könnte, aber ist, wenn sie mal hingehen und jetzt sagen, okay, mal back to the roots, wir versorgen erst mal die Leute, die noch nichts haben. Es gibt nämlich immer noch ganze Landstriche in Deutschland, quer durch ganz Deutschland, wo die Leute echt am Arsch sind auf dem Dorf. Und denen wäre wirklich geholfen, da mal, weiß ich, an die höchste Tannemahn in Nano-Stations dran zu hängen und damit in die nächste Kreisstadt zu wieben und dann runter ins Dorf zu leuchten und die ganzen Leute da überhaupt mal zu versorgen, statt jetzt, wie gesagt, neben die drölfzig Anbieter, die wir jetzt in den Städten haben, auch noch anstinken zu wollen. Das fände ich jetzt okay, aber gut, das ist halt jetzt nicht so... steht derzeit wohl nichts auf dem Plan. Da gibt es so andere Projekte, die sich damit befassen. Freifunk. Wir freuen uns, dass es euch gibt, aber nutzen halt, naja. Immer noch Networking. Liebe IcePeace, befolgt bitte endlich BCP38.
Ja, da hast du irgendwie rumgerantet.
Ja, ne, rumgerantet. BCP38 ist sozusagen so ein Super-RFC. Die meisten Leute wissen ja, was ein RFC ist. Das ist nämlich dieser Request for Commons sozusagen, diese Internet-Standard.
Also die Freak Show-Hörer wissen das auf jeden Fall.
Es gibt so Dinge, die sind so etabliert und so wichtig, das sind Best Common Practices. Das sind diese BCPs. Und der BCP38, der ist jetzt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, von 2000 oder 2001, das ist jedenfalls 15 Jahre alt. Und der sagt einfach nur, dass bitte doch ISPs mal aufhören sollten, IP-Pakete zu transportieren von ihren Kunden, die ihren Kunden nicht zugeteilt haben. Weil das ist ja heute immer noch so. Du kannst ja in die meisten Internet-Anschlüsse IP-Adressen, Pakete mit Source-Adressen reinpumpen, die dir aus den Fingern gesogen hast.
Also IP-Spoofing kann man betreiben, auch von zu Hause.
Kannst IP-Spoofing damit betreiben. Und zwar massenhaft. Und genau das tun nämlich all die Leute, die ihre schöne DINILE-OFF-SERVICE-Soft verteilen auf den PCs, in irgendwelchen Trojanern oder sonst irgendwas. Wenn die eben einmal so richtig Knülle machen wollen, dann senden die aus aller Welt, aus beliebigen IP-Adressen senden die kreuz und quer und machen halt so die Ziele, greifen die an. Wie zum Beispiel die Root-Name-Server gerade neulich, deswegen kam ich drauf. Ich habe da auch so ein paar Verbindungen dazu. Ich habe zwei Freunde, die da involviert sind in Root-Name-Server-Geschichten und die hatten jetzt Anfang Dezember mal ein bisschen zu tun. Es war nichts, denen es zwar nichts hinten übergefallen, aber trotzdem hat jemand gedacht, das wäre doch mal eine tolle Idee, wenn wir jetzt mal totknallen mit Request. Und so weit ist halt eben möglich, weil du immer noch, sagen wir mal, einen T-Online-Anschluss kannst du immer noch IP-Pakete reinschießen mit einer Source-Adresse, die dir die Telekom gar nicht zugewiesen hat. Und es ist relativ einfach, das zu unterbinden. Da gibt es inzwischen sogar bei den schnellen, großen Backbone-Routern, da gibt es sogar Hardware-Unterstützung für Revers, Paths, Checks und so. Und es wäre jetzt nach 15 Jahren wirklich langsam mal Zeit, dass man das mal auf die Reihe kriegt, dass Leute nur mit den IP-Adressen arbeiten, die man ihnen noch zugewiesen hat.
Wie verbreitet oder unverbreitet ist das? Also ich meine, wie viele wird der Provider machen?
Witzigerweise auf V6, wenn die Leute jetzt V6 anfassen, habe ich das häufiger erlebt, dass die das ordentlich filtern. Nach dem Motto, wenn wir das jetzt eh neu aufbauen, können wir das auch mal richtig machen. Das heißt, sie haben erkannt, dass das ein Problem ist und dass man das vielleicht richtig macht. Aber V4 fallen mir jetzt nur sehr wenig Leute ein, die das ordentlich checken. Wir machen das immer regelmäßig, wenn ich so Großveranstaltungen mache, machen wir regelmäßig immer einen so genannten WCP38-Filter rein. Wir filtern ja sonst eigentlich nicht bei ITF oder auch bei anderen Veranstaltungen. Es wird ja explizit sagen, wir lassen das alles offen. Allerdings, ihr spielt nur mit den Adressen, die wir euch gegeben haben. Ihr knallt nicht mit Adressen, die euch nicht gehören, hier durch die Gegend, weil da gibt es auch keine Rechtfertigung für. Und ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, wer das ist, weiß das jemand, ob jemand, der auf dem Kongress, da wird ja auch traditionell und aus religiösen Gründen nicht gefiltert, aber ob die wenigstens BCP 38 gibt oder nicht.
Das ist eine gute Frage, die ich dir nicht beantworten kann.
Aber man will ja auch ein bisschen spielen, also schon okay.
Naja, aber das fände ich jetzt durchaus legitim.
Du kannst ja vom Kongress noch ein Netz rausballern, das ist ja quasi kein Problem.
Du kannst jeden erreichen, aber die Frage ist, kannst du dafür beliebige Source-Adressen benutzen? Und da gibt es keinen legitimen Nutzen für. Es gab früher mal ganz, ganz...
Wenn ich dir einen Ping schicke und ich will aber, dass du zu Huckel-Zeug pingst, dann muss ich es ja huckeln. Das ist schon legitim.
Das ist sehr, sehr interessant. Ich bereite ja nun schon wieder ITF-Zeugs für nächstes Jahr vor. Und ich habe jetzt mal die Netze, die wir normalerweise auf den Meetings haben, habe ich jetzt mal aktuell mal angeknipst. Da ist aber nichts dahinter, wir haben jetzt null Teilnehmer. Das heißt, das Equipment sitzt jetzt irgendwo in Portland, irgendwo in so einem Lager. Und ich habe da sozusagen einen Pushbutton-Monkey, einen sehr netten, James heißt der, den kann ich dann anrufen, sagen, mach mal dit an, mach mal dit an und so. Und ich habe jetzt mal sozusagen die Netze annonciert, per BGP ins Netz, also ins große Internet, habe also gesagt, ja, die Adressen sind da, aber es ist nichts dahinter, also niemand, der antwortet. Und wenn ich da einen Netzadressbereich, den wir haben, ist Live 16, also 65.000 Adressen. Wenn ich den anmache, wo gesagt ist, nichts dahinter ist, kein Gerät dahinter, was die nutzt, nur das Announcen, dass sie existieren, habe ich einen Grundrauschen von 2, 2,5 Megabit, was hoch gibt es auf 20 Megabit. Das ist alles sozusagen Scheiß, der von außen auf so ein Netz einprasselt, den wir selber gar nicht verursachen, weil das ist ja kein Gerät da, was selber was macht, sondern sind nur Abpraller. Also man sieht richtig, dass andere Leute eben unsere Adressen benutzen, also mit Adress-Poofing, um jemanden anzugreifen und dessen Antworten sozusagen kommen als Kollateralschaden bei uns rein. Das geht teilweise bis auf 10.000 Pakete pro Sekunde hoch. Ich kann das übrigens gerne mal, wenn es da Interesse dran gibt, weil ich es selber auch auswerte und auch mit anderen Leuten hier auch aus Berlin auswerten will, ich erzeuge da Samples davon, also von diesem Grundrauschen. Und wer da mal Spaß dran hat, möge sich mal bitte melden, die Mail-Adressen sind interessant, dann kann ich euch mal so einen größeren Fall zur Verfügung stellen, wer mal auswerten will, was da so passiert. Ich hab mal so grob drüber geguckt, was eben sehr spannend ist. Was glaubt ihr denn, was jetzt gerade so der aktuelle Scan-Hype ist? Also was man sieht, sind wie gesagt so die Rückläufer von den Night of Souls Attacks, okay. Aber es gibt natürlich auch Leute, die scannen andauernd Internet. Mit dabei unsere chinesischen Freunde, ja, finde ich auch immer wieder toll, dass die große Firewall zwar jeden abhält, nur keine SSH-Requests und so, aber was glaubt ihr denn, was jetzt aktuell sehr der Scan-Hype ist, was man so sehr häufig oder fast ganz oben sieht?
Meinst du jetzt?
Also was die Leute ausprobieren. Die nuckeln halt deinen Adressraum durch, welche Ports genau, und was die Leute so ausprobieren, was bei dir so gerade offen ist.
Gibt mal einen Tipp jetzt, also ich meine...
Also SSH, SSH ist ein Klassiker. Es gibt übrigens Leute, die immer noch Telnet probieren. Nee, das ist auch nichts Neues. Aber was jetzt sozusagen der aktuelle schicke Hype ist, ist ZIP. Die Leute gucken, ob du da einen offenen Router oder ein offenes ZIP-Telefon hast und versuchen, irgendwelche abgefahrenen Nummern anzuwählen. Irgendwelche Fernnummern, 900er-Nummern. Also richtig versuchen, damit sozusagen wieder Geld zu erzeugen, auf der anderen Seite. Das ist jetzt der aktuelle heiße Scheiß, den ich da drin so sehe. Neben dem anderen, traditionellen Tralala. Ja, das ist nur wieder ein Hintern drauf, wer jetzt irgendwie sein Zip-Telefon offen am Internet hat. Also in der Regel so zwei. Aber da gibt es dann richtig so Bursts, die halten dann so an, ein paar Minuten oder so. Dann habe ich so 10.000 Pakete davon. Dann habe ich so 19, 20 Megabit Dreck. Auf einem Slash 16. Das muss natürlich hoch reihen, du musst jetzt teilen durch die Anzahl Adressen, 65.000 Adressen, die ich dort annonziere. Aber das ist sozusagen diese Grundrauschen. Sehr lustig.
Machen wir das doch mal.
Wann das ausrechnen?
20 Megabit durch, was hast du gesagt?
65.000.
Wir beweisen, dass wir Taschenrechner bedienen können.
Falsch, Dennis. Das ist ja kein Ethernet. Diese alte Scheiß-IPv4-Regel, dass du die erste und die letzte Adresse nicht benutzen kannst, das gilt ja nur für Broadcast-Netze. Das ist aber kein Ethernet an dieser Stelle. Das heißt, du kannst alle 65.536 Adressen adressieren, aus dem Internet, die ich da noch führe. Egal, also das ist wie gesagt, und alle Leute, die bei irgendwelchen ISPs arbeiten, können mal fragen, ob sie nicht mal jetzt zu ihrem Chef gehen, sagen, Frau Weihnachten, du, dürfen wir mal diese Flecke im Router anmachen, dass der Scheiß mal aufhört und so. Vor x Jahren gab es mal eine Anwendung dafür, die wird aber inzwischen heute eh anders gemacht. Es gab so Satelliten-Anbieter, die haben nur unidirektionalen Satellitenlink angeboten. Das heißt, du hattest nur den fetten Downstream sozusagen vom Satelliten runter, musstest aber deine Rückpakete, die man ja mal so zurückschicken muss, übers normale Telefon- oder ISTN-Netz oder halt sonst welches Internet abliefern. Aber diese Nummer ist eh passé. Also heutzutage ist, wer Satellit macht, macht eh bidirektionalen Satelliten. Und wer immer noch die erste Lösung braucht, also sich der Satellitenbetreiber vielleicht in den Tunnel schalten. Also es gibt keinerlei legitimen Grund mehr, über einen ISP-Anschluss, IP-Adressen oder Pakete mit Source-Adressen rauszuschicken, die einem nicht von diesem ISP zugewiesen wurden.
Drei Kilobit pro IP-Adresse. Grundrauschen.
Ja, wenn es mal, wie gesagt, ist der Burst. Aber wie gesagt, hast du jetzt die zwei Megabit mal?
20 Megabit hast du.
Ja gut, nee, ich sag 20 Megabit im Burst. Das ist das, was ich so sehe. Und wenn da nichts, wenn Frieden ist, dann schickert das so mit zwei Megabit vor sich hin. Aber war halt nur so ein Aufruf, weil ich dachte, ey, hallo, das ist jetzt so ein altes Ding, das können wir doch mal langsam auf die Reihe kriegen.
Ich frage mich, ob man da nicht einfach mal ISPs einfach mal für dran kriegen kann.
Nee, das ist ja gerade das Schöne. Das ist der Vorteil und der Nachteil in dieser ganzen Internetstruktur mit diesen IETF und RFCs und so weiter und so fort. Du kannst dich dran halten, du kannst dich auch mal wieder drauf berufen, aber du musst nicht.
Ja, aber dafür hat auch das Internet das Shaming erfunden.
Ja, aber ein ISP, der sich noch auf IPv4 konzentriert, der ist schon fertig geschämt. wcp38shaming.org gibt es garantiert. Gibt es garantiert, dass es Leute gibt, die sich damit auseinandergesetzt haben. Weil wie sagt das Ding, das ist echt alt.
So wie die meisten Freak Show Teilnehmer.
Ja, aber wenn ihr so private Netze wollt, ihr könnt auch übrigens auch, das ist eine schöne Sache, ihr könnt auch bitte mal aufpassen, was alles aus euren scheiß Routern raus tropft. Klassiker ist ja, die klassische Aufbau ist, du hast halt dein Internet mit einer öffentlichen V4-Adresse, sondern hast halt deine scheiß Router-Plaste da mit irgendwelchen privaten IP-Adressen dahinter, ja, FZ 1918, diese berühmten 192, 168-Adressen oder 10 oder so. Es gibt noch einen dritten Bereich, den aber keiner benutzt, weil sie die Mathematik wieder nicht beherrschen hinter einem Slash 12. 178. Ne, 172, 16, Slash 12. Aber jüt. Und dann kriegst du Leute immer wieder hier backen, denn Adressen aus diesen dreckigen Adressräumen nicht zu natten, bevor sie rauskommen. Das heißt, da purzeln auch wieder Adressen mit Source-Adressen, Pakete mit Source-Adressen aus diesem privaten Bereich, die nun definitiv nirgendwo niemals nicht erreichbar sind, purzeln wieder ins Internet raus. Ich muss leider da ein bisschen drunter. Ich habe ja noch alte Adressen von früher, von damals, unter anderem auch 192, nee, 192.68.0 und 192.68.1 zum Beispiel, die kann ich nicht benutzen. Wenn ich die anmache, werde ich so mit Paketen aus aller Welt vollgerotzt von Leuten, die zu doof sind, 192.168.1 zu tippen, dass ich diesen Adressraum schlichtweg nicht benutzen kann.
Das sehe ich schon irgendwann mal vom digitalen Menschengerechtshof klar.
Aber ich glaube, Dummheit ist nicht justiziabel.
So, bleiben wir doch mal bei den Netzen. Aber gehen wir mal auf etwas anderes, worüber wir schon gesprochen haben, nämlich Let's Encrypt. Das Projekt, was allen Menschen HTTPS zugänglich machen soll, in dem ist die Verteilung der dafür erforderlichen Zertifikate automatisiert.
Yeah, ein CA, CA hat mehr, also ein RUT-CA, mehr auf meinem Rechner, voll toll. Ja, noch toller. Das ist nicht so mein Konzept, ich finde das doof.
Wieso, was fällt dir da?
Ich mag nicht, dass ich irgendwelche RUT-Dinger auf meinem Rechner, wo die Leute was unterschreiben, was ich nicht weiß, was ich unterschreibe, und mir alles vollballern und mir sonst was unterjubeln. Ich finde das grundsätzlich vom Prinzip alles Schrott.
Ja gut, aber nachdem du 500 von denen schon weißt...
Aber dein Online-Banking und so, willst du trotzdem vielleicht von irgendeiner...
Ich müsste mir da per Post irgendwie so einen Code schicken, wenn ich auf deren Seite hier vergleiche.
Ja, was, ist nicht so schwer.
Aber Realität ist halt anders, ne?
Das ist echt nicht so schwer.
Dieser PKI-Gedanke, der funktioniert wirklich nur für in sich geschlossene Benutzergruppen, für öffentliche Netze. Es ist eigentlich natürlich schlauer, wenn man das Zertifikat zugeschickt kriegt.
Weil die jubeln unter was sie wollen. Das passiert ja auch andauernd. Wir haben außersehen Google gesagt. Wir haben nur einen Test gemacht. Der Studi hat außersehen unseren Master-Ki von unseren RUT-Dings bekommen.
Aber diese Kritik existiert ja schon lange, so berechtigt sie ist. Nur das allein hat halt nicht dieses System uns vom Hals geschafft. Und Let's Encrypt ist ja quasi ein Projekt, das einfach erst mal in den Hals geschaffen hat.
Und Let's Encrypt ist ja quasi ein Projekt, das einfach erst mal sagt, wenn wir schon diese ganze Scheiße an der Backe haben...
Warum macht es das noch kaputt?
Weil jetzt noch da eine Instanz ist, die noch mehr irgendwie Zeug signen, wo ich nicht weiß, was die da signen.
Signen ist ja auch noch gar nicht so böse.
Alles, was seine Kontrolle über seine Domänen nachweisen kann, nicht mehr und nicht weniger. Aber es ist erlaubt, überhaupt erst mal ohne Fehlermeldungen, kryptographisch abgesichert, HTTPS-Verbindung. Das führt einfach mal dazu, dass HTTPS jetzt überhaupt mehr Verbreitung hat.
Und vor allen Dingen wird dazu führen.
Das stimmt aber tatsächlich insofern wirklich. Das wirst du zugeben, besser ist, zu verschlüsseln als nicht zu verschlüsseln. Erstmal so, grundsätzlich.
Das hat es aber auch schon vor dem da funktioniert.
Aber du brauchst in dem System eine Zertifizierungsstelle. Nur so kann dieser Schlüssel ausgehandelt werden. Das ist in diesem System so. Wieso? Es ist in dem System so. Also wenn du hier oben ein grünes Icon haben willst, dann musst du...
Ja, wenn du da oben ein grünes Icon haben willst. Das betrifft aber nicht die Krypto. Das betrifft nicht die Sicherheit deiner Übertragung. Überhaupt gar nicht. 0, 7, 0. Das ist nur dafür da, damit du dich überfreust, dass da oben ein grünes... Das kriegst du übrigens auch nicht mit Let's Encrypt, weil damit du mit diesem grünen Ding da oben hinkommst, brauchst du ein Extended Validation Certificate.
Du musst nicht die Fehlermeldung wegklicken und die Übertragung ist erstmal so sicher, dass 99% deiner Angreifer ausgeschlossen sind. Das ist schon mal gut, weil das eine Prozent, was dich wirklich angreifen will, das kriegst du sowieso nicht von der Backe.
Ja, verstehe ich. Aber das hat mit der Zertifizierung nichts zu tun. Deine Übertragung ist auch sicher, wenn du einen Zertifizierer machst.
Aber dann benutzt es halt keiner.
Weil du diese Scheißmeldung wegklicken musst.
Man muss den Leuten nur sagen, dass das keine Fehlermeldung ist.
Vor allem, du kannst das im Chrom fast gar nicht mehr wegklicken.
Ja, selber Schuld als Opfer. Ich benutze das ja auch nicht mehr.
Dennis, Alter, man, ey. Die grumbligen, grauen Männer.
Vor allem ist das doch total weltfremd. Ich meine, wenn Omi da eine Fehlermeldung kriegt, dann klickt sie die Seite weg. Wer kommt nicht hin, kann nicht verschlüsseln, dumm gelaufen. Und für die Leute ist das. Das ist nicht für dich, weil du bist der Schlaue. Aber für den Rest der Welt ist es nicht nützlich.
Aber Omi kriegt dann auch irgendwann die anderen Zertifikate da untergejubelt, weil einer sonst was gesiegt hat.
Ja, aber sicher ist das sowieso nicht. Aber ist trotzdem besser verschlüsselt zu kommunizieren als unverschlüsselt. Das wirst du doch einsehen.
Da hat er leider recht.
Da waren wir uns ja einig, dass verschlüsselt wird so oder so. Es geht um diese Meldung.
Also du möchtest gerne ein anderes System. Das wollen wir alle. Und die anderen wollen erst mal unter den...
Gibt es eigentlich auf dem Kongress einen Talk, der heißt, warum TLS scheiße ist oder was auch immer? Krypto...
Es gibt auf jeden Fall einen Talk, aber letztendlich in Krypta kannst du ja dann ranten. Kannst dich schön als Mikro stellen und sagen, was verbessert dir hier die Welt, wenn sie noch viel besser sein könnte.
Jetzt macht ihr mal, ich will euch ja nicht dazwischenfucken, solltet ihr auch euren Spaß haben.
Unverhältnismäßig, Alter, da red ich ja eine halbe Stunde über Vectoring und über einen BCB, was kein Arsch kennt.
Das kann ich über Bitcoin reden, du hast keine Chance gehabt, Alter.
Ich sag ja, es kann heiter werden heute.
Was wolltest du denn, Tim? Was wolltest du denn sagen, zuletzt in Krypta?
Ich wollte sagen, dass seit dem 3. Dezember die Public Beta draußen ist.
Ja, das ist doch alles Python-Scheiße, hat Pefe geschrieben.
Deswegen kann man das nicht losbenutzen.
Wait a minute, du liest den Blog?
Nein, ich krieg nur ausgewählte Meldungen. Ausgewählte Meldungen von ausgewählten Meldungen krieg ich. Und manchmal leckt da halt was rein, und ich hab halt mitgekriegt, dass Pefe das Scheiß findet.
Ja, gibt's ja mittlerweile auch als Standalone-Version.
Ich weiß jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht so richtig, was da der Kritikpunkt ist.
Das Problem ist folgende. Die Idee, die dahintersteckt, ist gut. Wir verteilen jetzt hier mal Zertifikate, ohne sie für ein scheiß Geld und wilde Prozeduren anzuverkaufen, wie das so jetzt ein Jahrzehntelang lief. Deswegen geht auch schon manchen dieser Buden der Arsch auf Grundeis. War auch so ein schöner Ding dieser Tage, wo sich jetzt einer... Der vergoldete Arsch auf Grundeis. Wo jetzt jemand anfing, und schon wieder, keine Ahnung, bei Mozilla oder so, was ein Ticket aufgemacht hat, sie sollen doch bitte diese Zertifikate, Druh-Zertifikat, aus dem sich die letzten Encrypt-Dinger da ableiten, sollen sie doch bitte aus der Mozilla-Distribution rausnehmen, weil Spielregel bla und es gefällt mir alles nicht und so weiter und so fort. Und wenn man dann nachguckt, wer das war, ist das halt einer von diesen CEOs von so einer Bude, die sich da mit einem goldenen Arsch verdienen, hahaha. Ein Schelm, wer Böses dabei denkt, ja. Aber wie die auch sagen, die Idee dabei ist gut. Und Let's Encrypt hat weder TLS oder das Broken TLS, wie es heutzutage ist, zu verantworten, noch das Zertifikatsystem zu verantworten. Sie sagen halt, weil es scheiße ist, machen wir es ein bisschen besser. So ist der Ansatz. Die Idee finde ich toll. So, wie wollen sie es besser machen? Sie wollen es jetzt wieder so richtig, richtig, richtig dumm userfreundlich machen. Jetzt muss man sich mal überlegen, dass Zertifikate ja nichts sind, was jemand sich jetzt auf seinem Laptop installieren muss, sondern Zertifikate sind, was jemand auf seinem Server installieren muss. So, und um einen Server zu betreiben, brauchst du so mal ein Minimum-IQ. Ja, es gibt so fertige Sachen, so mit docker, klick hier und tralala und so was, aber trotzdem so ein Minimum-IQ brauchst du schon, um irgendwie mal einen Server aufzusetzen. Nichtsdestotrotz versuchen sie, durch ein wildes Gewusel aus, wie es immer gesagt wurde, Python-Scheiße, das so zu machen, dass du da am besten gar nichts machst. Das heißt, Zeugs inspiziert deine Konfiguration, deine Apache-Konfiguration, hackt deine Apache-Konfig falls um, generiert selber private Schlüssel, was das Heiligste ist an der ganzen Nummer, registriert die, also nicht die privaten Schlüssel, sondern die Public Keys und macht und tut, holt sich deine Zertifikate bei Let's Encrypt ab und patcht die dann in deine Apache-Konfig rein oder an deine EngineX-Konfig oder sonst irgendwas. Da kommt ein Skript, das sollst du dir aus dem Internet herunterladen und das wirfst du natürlich als Admin einfach mal an. Das ist genauso wie hier, hier hast du ein Stück Software für deinen Mac, das macht irgendwelche Sachen mit Private Keys in deinem Namen, vertraue mir, das ist alles supergut, lass das einfach laufen, das hackt ja deinen ganzen Computer so zurecht, dass das alles funktioniert. iMessage ist nicht dein General, das ist für iMessage, von iMessage für Apple und so weiter und so fort.
Ja, das ist genau das, was du gerade beschrieben hast. Das ist die Software, die generiert lokale Keys und Nutze.
Ja, aber die repräsentiert dich nicht generell auf deinem Server. Entschuldigung, wir reden jetzt, das ist gerade der Punkt, dass ich sage, dass du einen Unterschied machen musst zwischen irgendwelchen Dumm-User-Zeugs oder sowas, was die Leute draußen auf ihren Rechnern dann da haben, oder irgendwelchen Servern, die du betreibst. Und ich würde doch im Leben nicht irgendwie die Security von meinem Server, und die hängt da nämlich wirklich damit ab, weil diese Ding Private Keys generiert. Nochmal, das ist der heiligste Prozess an der ganzen Nummer. Das macht das einfach heimlich, still und leise, generiert das einfach Private Keys, macht damit irgendwas dort, die irgendwohin, oder was weiß ich, keine Ahnung, installiert sich die irgendwohin, und hackt dann auch noch meine Server-Konfiguration um.
Na, hallo?
Bitte dich, aber wir haben doch gerade festgestellt, dass es erst mal dazu da ist, die Situation zu verbessern, weil ohne das Ding bist du ja offensichtlich nicht in der Lage, dir dein eigenes Zertifikat zu machen, wenn du so ein IQ hast. Dann brauchst du aber auch Let's Encrypt nicht, weil du kannst ja auch.
Heute das schon machen. Dann musst du das nicht umsonst.
Du kannst ja auch mit einem höheren IQ rangehen, und es dann irgendwie so machen, wie du machen willst, und es gibt ja auch schon Software.
Habe ich Anleitungen durchprobiert, zwei gingen beide nicht.
Wie auch immer, das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt das Problem, was zum Veröffentlichen der Public Beta schon vollkommen gelöst sein wird, aber dass da jetzt relativ viel Energie drauf fließen wird, ist uns glaube ich auch klar.
Ja, trotzdem muss man halt schon sagen, ich finde das auch mal problematisch, wenn es so Produkte oder irgendwelche Services gibt, wo gesagt wird, klick diesen Button und alles wird gut und sicher und du musst dich gar nicht damit befassen, wie es funktioniert. Und gerade so bei diesen ganzen Kryptosachen, da würde ich auch sagen, muss man sich halt schon so ein minimal bisschen damit befassen, sonst ist es nicht sicher.
Ja, ja, pass auf, aber Tim, das ist schon richtig. Die Frage ist, ob es überhaupt richtig ist, so zu tun, als könne man ohne Sachverstand Server mit hoher Bandbreite in der Anbindung im Internet betreiben. Die Frage muss man sich schon stellen.
Ja, natürlich, aber ohne Sachverstand...
Ja, und wenn man Sachverstand hat, dann kann man sich auch ein Zertifikat installieren. Die Anleitungen sind alle schlecht, aber es gibt genügend Anleitungen, die spezifisch sagen, du musst dir ein Public Key generieren, und das funktioniert so und so, und dann machst du diese und jene Schritte, und am Schluss hast du das installiert. Das sind ja die Dinge, die du auch können musst, wenn dein Server zugekackt wird, oder wenn das Ding gehackt wird, oder was auch immer. Du musst dich mit der Technik befassen. Und so zu tun, als sei das nur eine Frage von irgendwie installier dieses Python-Skript, und dann bist du plötzlich sicher, das ist irgendwie... Also da kann man sich schon drüber streiten, ob das wirklich der richtige Weg ist.
Ja, aber mit der Argumentation kannst du ja auch sagen, du musst jedes einzelne HTTP-Methode, die da ausgetauscht wird, musst du auch noch irgendwie können und auswendig... Genau!
Wenn du so ein Ding betreibst, da! Nicht jeder muss einen Server betreiben.
Nein, das finde ich nicht. Auch Server betreiben muss einfacher werden, und da gehört auch so etwas dazu, dass sich...
Den Server nutzen muss einfacher werden, das stimmt dir zu.
Nein, Server betreiben muss auch einfacher werden, weil ich betreibe Server, und auch mein Know-how ist immer sehr an der Grenze des Minimums.
Das ist ja auch jetzt insgesamt schon ein ganz schön komplexer Scheiß, also ich meine...
Dann engagiert man einen professionellen Serverwirt.
Genau, wir von der Liga der Systemadministratoren wollen nicht unsere Jobs verlieren. Deswegen möchten wir, dass du uns dafür Geld gibst.
Ja, kannst du ja machen, ich meine, du gehst jetzt zu Uberspace, die haben jetzt irgendwie auch schon Let's Encrypt sozusagen schon komplett da in ihrem System deploit und machen da sozusagen ihre eigene Oberfläche da drüber. Und die verstehen das sicherlich, weil das ist sozusagen ihre Kernkompetenz und dann bist du dort Kunde und nutzt das.
Die haben sich da auch sehr genau nochmal angeguckt und auch diverse interessante Anmerkungen dazu gemacht. Gerade die Uberspace war doch ein bisschen shady, das einfach so zu nehmen, wie das da kommt. Das haben wir nochmal ein bisschen befummelt.
Gut, das gehört aber zu deren, sag ich mal.
Das ist auch okay. Das findet sich, aber es ist wichtig, dass diese Initiative überhaupt erst mal kam, weil es hat sich ja nichts verbessert.
Stimmt. Und wir hatten diese, genau diese Diskussion hatten wir vor 15 Jahren im Club, wo es darum ging, schalten wir www.ccc.de auf HTTPS um. Und es war genau die gleiche unsägliche Diskussion. Und jetzt machen die endlich mal was. Und insofern ist das ja auch...
Das ist nach wie vor gut, aber ich hätte mir auf jeden Fall gewünscht, dass sie nicht nur diese Peisen, wir kümmern uns um alles, denk nicht drüber nach, sondern eben auch gleich hier irgendwie schick deinen CSA, hier hast du deinen Zert fertig.
Also bist auch dafür, dass man eine Hütte baut, um die Fahrräder unterzubringen, aber du hättest sie lieber in rot gehabt.
Nee, das ist schon noch ein anderer Ansatz.
Das ist der falsche Vergleich jetzt, sorry.
Nicht alles, was hinkt, ist ein Vergleich. Ich hol mir mal ein Bier, will noch jemand eins.
Ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, ob das ein gutes Beispiel ist, aber es ist mir gerade so über den Weg gekommen. Und zwar gibt's... Habt ihr schon mal was von Caddy gehört?
Automatisch. Yet Another Server.
Ja, das ist ein in Go geschriebener Web-Server. Der ist irgendwie so recht frisch. Ich hab jetzt nicht im Detail daher.
Dann lasst uns den noch gleich offen ins Internet stellen. Was kann da schon schiefgehen?
Naja, auf jeden Fall, dieser Web-Server kommt sozusagen automatisch mit so Let's Encrypt-Support, das ist da sozusagen schon mit drin deployed. Weiß ich genau, wie es funktioniert, ob sie da jetzt in irgendeiner Form von den Python-Gaben genippt haben, aber da das selber in Go geschrieben ist, denke ich mal, das geht.
Es gibt ja auch eine API für das Let's Encrypt.
Genau, das war auch mein Verständnis, aber ich hab's nicht überprüft, dass sie halt hier an dieser Stelle das API benutzen und dass das sozusagen schon eine Eigenschaft des Servers selber ist. Und an der Stelle, das ist ja sagen wir mal auch die eigentliche Kerntätigkeit, die Let's Encrypt macht. Und wenn sie das jetzt erstmal mit irgendwelchen Python-Code-Bootstrappen und Leute dann unzufrieden sind und dann eben mit solchen Lösungen kommen, umso besser. Also warum sollte eben ein Apache oder ein Nginx oder was auch immer jetzt gerade der Webserver der Wahl gerade ist, eben nicht diese Fähigkeit dieses, ich gehe in diesen Prozess und ich begleite dich, Nutzer meiner Dienste, dabei hier das Richtige zu tun, ohne dass ich jetzt selber mit irgendwelchen kryptischen Konfigurationsfalls mich rumschlagen muss und ich muss sagen, einfach dieser ganze Key-Scheiß, ich habe das einfach jedes Mal nicht hinbekommen.
Der State of the World in Sachen Krypto ist auch wirklich furchtbar. Es gibt auch Dutzende Anleitungen, die dir irgendwie erklären, dass du dein Key erstmal mit einem Schlüssel erzeugen sollst und dann musst du den Schlüssel hinterher entfernen, weil irgendein Idiot mal nicht wusste, dass man Minus Nodes sagen muss. Und das findest du in Dutzenden, in Hunderten Anleitungen für deine CA-Generierung. Niemand erklärt wirklich, wie man ein CA hat. Es gibt keine vernünftige CA-Software.
Und es gibt auch irgendwo einen geheimen Crypto for the Masses Podcast. Den müssen wir nur noch mal wiederfinden.
Das ist die Software, die dann immer ständig die Keys verliert.
Keinen einzigen.
Es ist besser als OpenSSL. Und auch diese ganzen Easy-CA-Sachen. Das ist alles schlecht. Das ist zum Beispiel auch so eine Sache. Das es keine Möglichkeit gibt, sich selbst mal ein Verständnis davon zu schaffen, was ist so eine PKI-Infrastruktur? Und sich dann selbst eine zu bauen und dann zu sagen, hier du kriegst mein RU-CA, du und du und du. Und wir können jetzt sicher miteinander kommunizieren, weil eigentlich ist das nicht schlecht und es ist auch nicht kompliziert. Aber diese ganze Technik, die da drunter steht, die ist in derartig böserweise kaputt. Und die ganzen How-To's kommen...
Und die Waschzettel, die How-To's sind wirklich...
Das ist alles grauenhaft.
Aber ich fand zum Beispiel, wir haben ja, bei VUGA sind wir jetzt, wie gesagt, bei diesem Premium-SSL oder Zert-Provider, hier bei Digi Zert. Und da war es ja so schön, wir haben hier so ein GUI-Tool, um dir so dein CSA zu klicken. Und ich dachte mir schon, okay, jetzt mal sehen, was passiert. Also schön mit Form. Und es füllt sich automatisch aus. Und dann steht da so Generate. Und dann dachte ich mir so, und macht jetzt den Key? Oder macht der nicht den Key? Und wenn du auf Generate klickst, dann geht dieses Form weg. Und dann steht ein Open-SSH-Kommando mit allen Feldern ausgefüllt, was du halt wirklich dann nur in dein Terminal pastest. Und dann kommt der Key ohne Passphrase und alles schon schnickibunti da. Aber ich dachte mir immerhin so an der richtigen Stelle. Weil es gibt ja auch genug Provider, die dir mittlerweile den Key dann auch gleich vorgelegt haben.
Für Extended Validation wollte da aber nichts ausgeben. Die Oma nämlich ganz traurig. Sie hat jetzt nämlich nur ein kleines grau Schlösschen dargestellt. Omas eben.
Ja, wir brauchen keine Extended Validation. Wir verkaufen ja nichts auf unserer Webseite.
Vor allen Dingen nicht an Omas.
Oma ist traurig.
Kedi in go geschriebener Web-Server, leicht zu konfigurieren, guck ich mir an.
Also kriegst du mit einer Zeile Konfigurationsdatei das Ding schon unter einer Domain. Und wenn du nicht hinschreibst, dass er HTTP machen soll, mach dabei Default HTTPS und holt dir gleich automatisch, wenn du die Kontrolle über die Domain hast, über dieses Let's Encrypt Nifty.
Ich hab nämlich jetzt gerade vor drei oder vier Wochen ein Apache mit Server-Site im Blut aufgesetzt.
Nein, nein, man macht heute kein Apache mehr, man macht kein Apache mehr.
Es war schlimm, aber ich konnte es noch auswendig.
Das ist halt auch ein alter Hase, kennst du von früher, ne?
Ja, aber das Ding ist halt irgendwie, ja ich weiß nicht, also diese ganzen, wie Clemens schon sagte, irgendwie bei diesen Server-Sachen, so dieses hier schmeiß hin, klick einen Button und es läuft schon und dann hast du irgendwas gebaut, was Leute tatsächlich interessiert und wunders dich, warum deine Webseite zwei Wochen down ist und überhaupt nicht mehr her der Lage wirst, ne?
Es muss sich aber schon annähern, ne? Weil Netzwerkdienste anbieten, ist einfach eine Commodity-Sache. Das ist nichts mehr, wo man irgendwie Freak für sein muss, ne?
Tim guckt gerade mit großen Augen auf das tolle Feature von Caddy, nämlich, dass es auch im HTTPS-Betrieb auch SNE supported. SNE ist die Server Name Indication. Das ist ein besonders toller Gag, ein feuchter Traum für alle Datenhungrigen auf dieser Welt. Es ist nämlich so, dass wenn du mehrere Webseiten unter einer IP-Adresse betreiben willst, was ja in der IPv4-Welt immer noch sehr common ist, dann hast du normalerweise ein Problem mit HTTPS, weil der Server muss ja ein Zertifikat präsentieren, was zu dem Namen deiner Webseite passt. Wohlgemerkt zu dem Namen und nicht zu der IP-Adresse. Wenn du aber jetzt mehrere Domain-Namen auf einer IP-Adresse hast, dann hast du so ein Catch-22, nämlich der Browser kommt an, geht nach www.blafasel.com oder HTTPS www.blafasel.com und möchte dementsprechend dort auch ein Zertifikat für www.blafasel.com finden. Damit es sozusagen möglich wird, das aufzulösen, wird mit diesem SNI-Mechanismus der Name des erwarteten Servers mitgeschickt. Das heißt, der Browser sagt vorher schon, was er gerne für ein Zertifikat sehen will. Und das natürlich im Klartext, weil da hat noch gar keine Session oder irgendwas stattgefunden. Das heißt also Leute, die jetzt Netze mitlesen, da sollte ja wohl welche von geben, hat Herr Snowden neulich mal erzählt, brauchen gar nicht großartig rumzuentschlüsseln, was dafür HTTPS-Request, also nicht den Request selber, aber wohin der geht, weil sozusagen der Name des angesprochenen Servers im Klartext vorne drin steht. Aber immerhin erlaubt es dem Server, bevor er seine erste Antwort schickt, sich das richtige Zertifikat rauszusuchen. Der Knaller ist, es gibt sogar so lustige Proxies, die generieren sich schnell in Zertifikat. Das heißt, die gucken nach, was du fragst. Und du fragst gerade nach www.google.com? Na komm, generiere dir mal www.google.com. Da gibt es richtig schöne fertige Software dafür, die man dafür benutzen kann als Proxies und so weiter.
Naja, aber ich meine, das S&I löst ein echtes Problem.
Natürlich löst es das Problem.
Dass du nicht mehr pro SSL Server eine IP-Adresse brauchst.
Ich sage nur, es hat einen Nebeneffekt.
Ja gut, aber auch hier ist der Vergleich wieder HTTP.
Vollkommen richtig.
Also ich hab, wie gesagt dieser Caddy, mir ist er zufällig, als ich dieser ganzen letzten Crypt-Geschichte etwas hinterher geklickt habe, ist mir der auf einmal ins Auge gefallen. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr wo. Klingt ganz interessant. Go, denke ich mal, ist auch jetzt nicht die schlechteste Basis für den Webserver und keine Ahnung, falls jemand da Erfahrungen hat, würde ich da gerne in den Kommentaren was zu lesen. Vielleicht wäre das ja mal was, wo man auch mal so mal Apache loswerden könnte oder so, weil der ist hier irgendwie Multi-Core und Pipapo und das ist jetzt mal was.
Apache kann man schon ganz lange loswerden, also das ist wirklich...
Ja, oder auch... Das Problem ist, es gibt halt so viele alte Installationen, da geht es eben nicht, weil da irgendwie Mod Perl von 1874 drin ist, mit, höre ich, 350 Modulen, die du da noch nachlädst und es gibt halt eben keine Nginx-Variante davon. Das ist das Problem, es ist immer... Ja, es gibt nicht. Es ist immer diese Legacy-Nummer.
Und Light-Hard-TV auch inzwischen, wenn du bei FreeBSD da mehr Config machst in dem Port, dann musst du scrollen, weil...
Das ist alles Schrott.
Aber, wie Roddy mal meinte, hier bei Audio-Engines, alle vier Jahre meintest du, muss man die mal neu schreiben, oder alle acht Jahre?
Na, alle zehn Jahre.
Alle zehn Jahre, ja. Also das ist dann bei Web-Servern wahrscheinlich auch so, da muss man...
Nein, alle zehn Jahre kommt jemand und schreibt eine neue und alle anderen sehen dann sehr alt aus.
Ja, das ist bei Web-Servern gefühlt auch so ein bisschen, ne? Also als Engine-Extra offen.
Schneller, schneller.
Ja, schneller. Aber so, es gibt so diese Evolutionsstufe. Ich weiß noch, als Engine-Extra so rauskam und einfach alles so an die Wand geblasen hat auch und einfach die Konfig auch das erste Mal so, ah, man kann das lesen und verstehen und es macht Sinn.
Übrigens so einer guten Hard-DPS-Konfiguration gehört nicht nur ein Zertifikat reinzuschmeißen, was von irgendjemandem mal unterschrieben wurde, sondern auch eine ordentliche Konfiguration der Krypto. Wenn man es richtig ist, macht man OCSP-Stapeling mit an und andere tolle Features und Trans Server und Certificate Transparency ist jetzt der neue heiße Scheiß, den Google ins Spiel bringen will, das macht man auch alles noch mit an. Das ist alles noch wieder viel gefummelt, ja, aber immerhin um diese, Oma will dieses Kästchen da nicht wegklicken, dieses Warnungskästchen, dafür reicht das alle mal.
Du hast ja mal ein Krumm, das ist kein Kästchen, das ist ein, oder bei Firefox oder so, da kommt der Polizist mit dem Schlagstock, wie ich ihn gerne nenne, aber, ne?
Oma hat nix mit, Omas leben einfach jetzt noch lange genug, die meisten Opas sind alle schon tot.
Meine Erfahrung ist, Opa lässt Oma machen.
Genau. There you go.
Wo ist denn mal so ein kaputtes Zert?
Das heißt, dass Oma viel mehr Erfahrung hat als Opa.
Also, die Omas und Opas, die ich so erlebt habe, da ist das tatsächlich so. Das meistens die Omas irgendwie dann...
Ich glaube, auf meiner Webseite....
die Rechner aufklappen.
smyg.net.
Was ist da mit smyg.net?
Ich glaube, da habe ich ein Self-Sign expired.
Also, ich würde einfach aus generellen Erwägungen darauf bestehen, dass wir nicht unbedingt Oma immer unterstellen, dass wir sozusagen den niedrigsten, wie soll ich sagen, Interaktionslevel mit der restlichen Welt haben.
Das war, war. Das hängt jetzt nicht an ihrem Geschlecht.
Früher haben wir Mutti gesagt, also das ist schon eine Verbesserung.
Hallo, es hängt nicht an ihrem Geschlecht, der Oma. Kannst du auch eine Transgendered-Oma oder eine Eichhörnchen-Oma haben?
Ich sag einfach die Großeltern.
Die Großeltern. Der, der das kommuniziert, war wieder die älteren Leute.
Jemand, der sich dafür nicht interessiert.
Jemand, der sich dafür nicht interessiert. Können wir dafür mal irgendwie ein kurzes Mem empfinden?
Generation Telegram.
Your connection is not private. Automatically report. Und dann gibt es unter advanced, gibt es proceed, unsafe, aber wirklich unter advanced. Das ist unsicher, sieht man doch.
Ich habe halt HTTPS nur für den WordPress-Login an und den sieht der normalo User halt nicht.
Ist doch ganz einfach, man muss nur Google davon überzeugen, dass diese Seite unnötig ist und sie einfach immer das so machen sollen. Ohne Warnung.
Ich habe ja, wie gesagt, ich habe ja auch diesen HTTPS musste halt vorschreiben.
Was machst du da keine automatische Drehdirektion?
Ja, alles andere.
Gehört alle mit dazu.
Hat dein letztes Encrypt-Skript gar nicht gemacht. Hast wieder nicht aufgepasst.
Mein Mail-Server, der ist richtig konfiguriert für den WordPress-Login, da ist mir das scheißegal, ob da...
Vorsichtig, was du sagst.
Geh mal hier auf Mail-Test, oder?
Dein Zertifikat.
Na und?
Das heißt, nur ein Test für eine kaputte... er wollte halt die Warnung im Chrom sehen. Deswegen hab ich ihm diese Seite jetzt empfohlen, quasi. Aber, nochmal, was ich sagen wollte, ich hab ja diesen Kurs an der UDK, ich hab gleich Kunststudenten das Internet, fang ja auch im Urschleim an, dann gibt's halt auch diese Frage zur Verschlüsselung, und dann zeig ich denen auch so den Polizisten mit dem... Das ist halt kein Schlagstock mehr, ist ja nur noch so ein kleiner Zeigestock. Und so, und fragt die so, ok, wenn das jetzt bei meinem Online-Banking passieren würde, was würde der machen? Continue oder abbrechen, ne? Und es gibt immer noch auch 2015 genug Studenten, die sagen, naja, ich will ja Online-Banking benutzen, also Continue.
Oder dann halt so da sitzt so... Sie gehen ein Recht nicht in den Vertrag ein Jahr in ein Jahr.
Wenn du jetzt Geld witz musst, dann jetzt hier von der Brücke springen.
Ok, ich will ja mein Geld. Genauso wie diese EU-Cookie-Warnung, die auch jeder kriegt und jeder wegklickt, und wo sie die Albumscheine schreibt.
Das ist ein Training.
Leute, nicht alle durcheinander, bitte.
Doch, macht doch Spaß.
Nein, das macht keinen Spaß. Es ist ganz interessant, diese ganze Debatte, wir hatten das vorhin ja schon mit diesem sinnlosen HTTPS-Zertifikat für WWCCCDE. Ich hab dann auch mal so, Leute, ich war ja mal auf eurer Webseite, das war ja cool.
Weil ich kenne ja unsere Webseite, die ist nicht cool. Also nicht die Bode cool.
Ich so, ja, was wie? Ja, da kam so eine Fehlermeldung, so mit Fehlern und so. Ich wusste immer, worauf es sich denn aus wollte. Also ich dachte, das wäre so...
Hacker-Challenge.
Ja, so, ah, der CTT, der kann mir dann sogar, wenn ich im Websurf so eine Fehlermeldung erzeugen. So, nee, das ist nicht so ganz das, was wir eigentlich... Also es gab ja mal diesen Traum dieses Bildungsauftrages, wenn wir jetzt auf WC-CDE ein kaputtes Zertifikat machen, und alle müssen darüber surfen...
Das ist ja nicht kaputt.
Ist nur abgelaufen, oder was?
Es war selbst signiert.
Aber es war aus Sicht aller Browser, war es sozusagen ungültig.
Man hätte ja auch einfach ein gültiges Zertifikat kaufen können.
Ja, hätte man aber, dann hätte man sich ja mit dem Finanzmammon und irgendwie den Luminaten und so weiter abkriechen müssen.
Aber nur online bezahlt, ja leider.
Ja, aber das war ja das Absurde.
Und was hat es gebracht an Bewusstseinsmachung? Seit wann gibt es das? Seit 10 Jahren?
Na ja, du weißt es jetzt auch nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Du hast ja nicht die ganze Userbase gefragt.
Alter, das hat einfach gar nichts gebracht.
Aber wir haben jetzt ja ein letztes Inkryptzertifikat.
War das jetzt Slow Clap oder was?
Die Sache war halt, wie gesagt, ich hab ja auch schon mit ein, zwei Leuten aus dem Berliner Umfeld konspirativ geplant, einfach ein Set zu kaufen, weil das ja schon auch einigen Berliner durchaus auf den Zünder ging. Und dann genau zu dem Zeitpunkt, als wir das tun wollten, war in Brach auf intern eine riesen Debatte wieder zu dem Thema los. Und ich dachte mir so, okay, nee, ich schalt jetzt nicht einfach das Zert um, sonst gibt's hier gleich irgendwie Flame, Deluxe.
Sieht nicht gut aus mit deiner Seite, okay.
Ja, die Seite ist scheißegal.
Nee, aber deine Zerts und so?
Ja, ist doch egal. Also, das benutze ich nur für den WordPress-Login, da ist sonst nichts mit irgendwie User-Daten und so.
Super. Ja, mal gucken. Jetzt musst du das nur noch für die Meta-Ebene hinkriegen.
Komm, Tim, jetzt schaffst du.
Hörst du dir einfach den Crypto-Forder erstens nochmal an und dann weißt du, wie es geht.
Aber hier.
Alleine werde ich das sicherlich kaum hinbekommen, weil die Downtime wäre dann zu lang. Aber mal schauen, ich bin ganz zuversichtlich, da ausreichend Verbünde zu finden. Weil da muss eh einiges umgezogen und umgestellt werden. Das Problem ist, so eine Podcast-Site kann man nicht so richtig lange offline nehmen.
Du kannst ja auch erstmal vorsichtig rangehen, wenn du deinem WordPress nicht draus und deinem Apachen.
Ja, aber es muss eh alles neu aufgesetzt werden, dann kann man dann auch gleich so full Monty machen. Warum nicht hier irgendwie Caddy?
Wenn dein WordPress unter Caddy läuft...
Du Onkel Tim, was ist der Full Monty?
Full Monty?
Du kennst den Film nicht, oder?
Welchen?
Ja, the Full Monty.
Ich hab das schon oft gehört, aber ich hab das immer überflogen, wusste nie, was das ist.
Es geht um ein paar Typen, die ein bisschen planlos sind und meinten, mit drittem Geld verdienen zu können.
Also man muss den nicht mal gucken.
Ja, doch, der ist schon ganz nett.
Bevor wir dieses leidige Thema verlassen, wollte ich gerne noch was anfügen, zum Thema SSL unterschreiben und umsonst. Ja, weil ihr driftet gerade schon wieder ab. Ich wollte nur sagen, was es schon länger gibt, ist eine relativ günstige CA, nämlich eine, wo man sich nur einmal alle zwei Jahre anmelden muss. Und für diese Prüfung der Anmeldung, also Prüfung eurer Identität, wollen die da für 50 Dollar haben. Und danach könnt ihr euch zwei Jahre lang euch Zertifikate unterschreiben, bis der Arzt kommt. Das halte ich für einen durchaus vernünftigen Deal. Das mache ich auch schon seit langem. Start SSL heißt die Bude.
Der Start SSL ist nur leider oft kaputt.
Nee, es wird gerne mal zugekackt von irgendwelchen Leuten. Also wird gerne mal gedost. Aber wir sehen davon die Zertifikate, die unterschrieben sind, okay.
Du kannst das auch ganz kostenlos nutzen.
Wo die IMD-Keys machen, bei denen.
Du kriegst dann einen Client-Zert, mit dem kannst du dich da anmelden. Die Oberfläche ist wirklich echt zum Schreien.
Du kannst das auch ganz kostenlos kriegen. Da kannst du aber nicht alle Sachen machen. Ich habe zum Beispiel gerne sogenannte White-Card-Zertifikate, die kriegst du nicht umsonst. Und wie gesagt, alle zwei Jahre, den mal 50 Dollar hinterherzuschmeißen, das finde ich durchaus okay.
Kriegst du aber halt auch nichts für, ne?
Doch, du kannst alles unterschreiben.
Ich meine, die Sache ist ja, wir sind ja dazu Digi-Zert gegangen, weil bei uns sind ja die Teams alle so unabhängig und die machen alles ihr eigenes Zeug, sprich, die nehmen halt auch alle SSL-Zertanbieter, die nicht bei Drafen Bäumen sind. Es gibt keine Übersicht, wer eigentlich welche Zerts hat und wenn mal eins abläuft und dann das Backend irgendwie mal so eine halbe Stunde oder Stunde nicht erreichbar ist, deswegen ist das halt doof. Das ist ja der optimale Fall. Das ist ja meistens noch länger da und war mal einen halben Tag ein Spiel da und deswegen. Aber nicht so Leute, also dann lass uns doch einfach alle Zertifikate mal bei einem anbieter haben, dann haben wir wenigstens einen Überblick, welche wann ablaufen und so weiter. Und die machen ja dann zum Beispiel, du kriegst ja dann auch, wenn du dafür ordentlich bezahlst, kriegst du ja dann auch so schöne Garantiesummen versprochen, ob das jetzt wirklich was bringt. Das ist ja die andere Frage, aber sie sagen quasi, wenn irgendein Scheiß mit unserem Zert passiert und es irgendwelche Probleme gibt, dass irgendjemand jetzt hier unser Routesert stiehlt, eure Domänen selber signen und irgendeinen Scheiß damit macht, dann habt ihr hier so sozusagen eine Million Dollar oder so. Schreiben sie dir dann da gut, ne? Das, also ich meine, ja...
Klingt fast so gut wie wie ein Scanner auf dem PC.
Jaja, genau, also... Aber ich fand's halt ganz interessant, mal zu gucken, was die einem dann so alles so quasi dann für das Geld, abgesehen von diesem tollen Management-Interface, was auch wirklich gar nicht so schlecht ist, noch so alles versprechen. Na, ich würde mal sagen... Naja, das ist jetzt schwierig, weil jetzt gibt's ja wirklich so Erderutsch-mäßig mit den Preisen, ne? Also es hat ja...
Was hast du jetzt bisher bezahlt bei Digita?
Also sagen wir mal, bei Rapid SSL hast du ja glaube ich ein Einjahrzertifikat vor kurzem noch für 99 Dollar im Jahr bekommen.
Aber du zahlst pro Zertifikat? Ja, sag dir, bei Start SSL einmal alle zwei Jahre, dass du feststellst, dass du du bist und unterschreibst 30 Millionen Zertifikate.
Genau. Da hast du halt dafür ein ordentliches User-Interface. Du hast auch zum Beispiel coole Features wie du kannst dir für das gleiche Zert kostenlos verschiedene Keypairs machen. Also du kannst sozusagen, wenn du sozusagen bei manchen Providern musst du halt ein Key hochladen, wenn die für dich zum Beispiel beim CDN Content serven wollen. Und dann kannst du denen ein eigenes Key Pair machen und das auch einzeln revoken ohne sozusagen Aufpreis und solche Sachen. Also es gibt schon auch ganz coole Features, wenn man dafür bezahlt.
Das ist ja nicht, wenn du da ein Ding draußen hast, dann hast du das draußen und unterschreiben sie dich nochmal. Das kannst du revoken, das kostet auch wieder Geld.
Naja, Annie Huse, wie auch immer, ist auch eine Bingo-Karte, oder?
Auch immer, das ist auch eine Bingo-Karte, das stimmt.
Jetzt müssen wir mal wieder über was anderes reden als über Netze.
Ja, finde ich auch.
Ich bin auch schon dabei, hier ein bisschen umzusortieren. Wir können ja mal zu etwas vollkommen anderen kommen und zwar... To something completely different. Und zwar Flatter. Ja, also wir haben das Thema ja ab und zu mal. Und vor einem Jahr gab es ja schon mal die vollmundige Ankündigung von Flatter, alles anders zu machen und dabei vor allem auch den, ich finde, Hauptkritikpunkt des Systems anzugehen, nämlich den Payment-Prozess, bzw. den Geldüberweisungs-Hin-und-Herschiebungs-Prozess. Ja, das haben sie vor einem Jahr angekündigt. Dann gab es diese Vorlaufzeit mit, ihr müsst jetzt hier mal den neuen Terms zustimmen, weil sonst können wir euren Datenbestand nicht ein neues System übernehmen, weil ein anderer Payment-Provider bzw. auch andere Payment-Provider-Architektur pipa po. Und dann waren sie, glaube ich, so mit dem Rücklauf eine Weile nicht so richtig zufrieden, um sofort voll durchzumarschieren. Und dann gab es aber auch noch sehr viele Detailprobleme hinter den Kulissen, die viel mit den Fähigkeiten oder Unfähigkeiten von Payment-Provider so zu tun haben. Ja, und immer wenn man glaubt, es geht nicht mehr weiter, ist dann doch was passiert. Und seit einem Tag oder so gibt es eine neue Webseite. Die ist jetzt extrem spartanisch. Ich finde insbesondere, wenn man eingeloggt ist, ist die schon viel zu spartanisch. Also wenn man jetzt normalerweise auf die Homepage kommt, dann hat man halt so dieses typische...
Dann hat man ein Hintergrundbild sonst nicht.
Ja, vor allen Dingen finde ich ja die Sublinder. Pay-for-free-Content ist halt auch irgendwie... Also wenn du payst, dann ist es halt nicht... Hatte einer auf Twitter schon gemeint, wäre vielleicht besser so Support-free-Content oder...
Steht da ja auch. Support-free-and-open-web. Pay-for-free-content.
Pay-for-free-content.
Also ich würde jetzt meinen, dass das sehr wohl gewählt ist. Die haben sich extrem viele Gedanken darüber gemacht in den letzten Jahren, was das sozusagen ist, was sie da tun. Und das mag jetzt hier so ein bisschen die Summe dessen sein. Wie auch immer, die Webseite ist jetzt deutlich aufgeräumter und das hat auch was damit zu tun, dass es quasi Mobile First ist. Also vorher war ja Flutter auf mobilen Geräten unbenutzbar. Und jetzt ist es halt anders. Jetzt ist es andersrum. Na ja, wie man es nimmt. Und ja, es ist halt extrem reduziert. Das heißt, wenn man sich irgendwie einloggt, dann kann man da gerade mal so sein Budget festlegen und kriegt so einfache Übersichten, was man so an Flutters ausgegeben hat und auch Empfang hat. Neu ist, das war schon lange mein Wunsch, dass man jetzt eben sieht für diese einzelnen Flutterklicks, oder sie reden jetzt einfach nur noch von Flutters, dass man jetzt auch sieht, über welches System dieser Flutter erzeugt wurde. Und da ist, zumindest jetzt in meinem Fall, war ich sehr überrascht, wie viel Software hier ist im Vergleich zu einzelnen Flutter-Buttons. Also vor allem, wenn ich hier mal durchscrolle, Antennapod, Podkicker, Podcast-Addict, Beyond Flutter, das ist so eine Erweiterung für Beyond Pod, um Flutter zu machen, diverse Antennapod-Forks, hier und da auch mal noch diese Webseiten wie Flatterstar und Instacast ist auch nochmal dabei. Aber im Wesentlichen sind es jetzt tatsächlich die ganzen Android-Clients, die jetzt hier abliefern, weil die halt diese ganzen Integrationen haben und darüber kommt, sagen wir mal, eine ganze Menge. Natürlich auch dann so sogenannte Recurring Flatters, also was vorher Subscriptions hieß, also wenn man so einen Button angeklickt hat und gesagt hat, bitte wiederholen. Mal gleich nochmal anschauen, ob sich das User-Interface auf den Buttons auch geändert hat. Na ja, und das zeigen sie einem eben jetzt. Aber was halt noch viel wichtiger ist, man kann jetzt eben auch Geld per Bank überweisen. Das war ja sagen wir mal aus Deutschland immer so eigentlich der Wunsch Nummer eins, dass man eben nicht über PayPal oder eben dann zuletzt über dieses komische Skrill gehen muss. Ich weiß, dass das flättern beiden.
Auszahlen oder einzahlen bei denen?
Beides.
Beides geht jetzt. Genau.
Das heißt, vorher konnte man auch nur über PayPal einzahlen bei denen?
Du musstest immer diesen Umweg gehen. Und das war jetzt auch nicht einfach so eine Entscheidung, die sie gefällt haben, sondern das war halt einfach extrem schwierig, diese Brücke zu bauen. Und zwar sowohl aus technischen, als auch aus legalen Gründen.
Ja, deswegen habe ich erzählt, diese Bitwaller-Bude, die ist zwar eine Berliner Bude, aber die machen ihr Business auch aus Amsterdam, weil in Deutschland ging das gar nicht.
Genau, sowas. Und bei Flatter war es halt England, weil sie diesen Status des Money-Agents haben und es keine Bank und so weiter. Und das ist einfach auch ein Problem mit der Regulierung in Europa, wo einfach vieles zwar theoretisch auf europäischer Ebene beschlossen wird, aber dann eben selten konkret in den einzelnen Ländern auch in Gesetze gekippt wird. Und dann hast du halt einfach keine Möglichkeit, dir da einen beliebigen Ort auszusuchen, von wo du aus aktiv werden willst. Und bei den ganzen Banking- und Internetsachen kommt halt noch dazu, find mal eine Bank, die halt wirklich dir dann auch eine API bereitstellt, mit der du arbeiten könntest, etc. Mittlerweile gibt es halt sowas und sie sind jetzt eben auf dieses Mango Pay gewechselt und Mango Pay arbeitet halt anders, als das vorher der Fall war. Vorher, das war ja auch etwas verwirrend, war das ja bei Flatter so, man hatte ja im Prinzip zwei Wallets. Man hatte sozusagen das Geld zum Ausgeben und man hatte das Geld, was man bekommen hat. Und wenn du das Geld, was du bekommen hast, wieder ausgeben wolltest, musstest du quasi von der einen Tasche in die andere Tasche explizit nochmal auf der Webseite so eine Transaktion machen. Das war aber nicht, weil die es nicht besser hätten machen können, sondern weil das einfach juristisch erforderlich war, diese Trennung dieser beiden Wallets vorzunehmen. Und ja, die Auszahlung dann über PayPal und Skrill war dann eben auch nicht sonderlich effizient und mit hohen Wegezoll geparrert. Denen wird es jetzt sicherlich immer noch geben, aber das ist deutlich weniger, auch wenn ich es jetzt gerade nicht benennen kann. Man kann also auf jeden Fall Geld dann abheben. Derzeit ist diese Funktion noch gesperrt, weil sie jetzt erst mal das neue System, wollen sie jetzt erst mal testen, also sozusagen im Live-Betrieb testen. Und es kann sein, dass das noch ein, zwei Wochen dauert. Aber wir sind dran. Und ich habe auch so hintenrum nochmal ein bisschen gechattet mit denen und nicht mal so versichert. Und die haben also sehr viele Probleme des ersten Tages, haben sie schon hinter sich gebracht. Und das andere sind im Wesentlichen Sicherheitsmaßnahmen, weil wenn es um Geld geht, wisst ihr ja auch, sollte man doch halt sehr vorsichtig sein. Und Historien und so weiter, das kommt dann halt auch alles irgendwie noch und Notifications. Ja, was ist davon zu halten? Also die haben halt diese ganzen Thing-Seiten und so weiter alles weggeschmissen. Eigentlich gibt es nur noch irgendwie Flatters, die werden übergeben, aber die werden nicht groß auf dieser Webseite dokumentiert, weil das hat irgendwie eh keiner verstanden. Debatten gibt es halt nach wie vor, dieses C-System gibt es nach wie vor, aber es gibt halt jetzt kein Verzeichnis mehr. Aber dafür kann man das eben jetzt an eine Bank koppeln. Das Problem noch ist, dass wenn man jetzt per Bank einzahlen will, dann, also es gibt jetzt mehrere Möglichkeiten. Man kann halt entweder Kreditkarte machen, man kann theoretisch GiroPay benutzen, funktioniert gerade aber irgendwie nicht.
Only available for our German users.
Ja, ich spreche da jetzt gerade nur Fehler, keine Ahnung. Dann gibt es diese etwas obskure Sofort-Überweisung, das will man wahrscheinlich nicht benutzen und dann kann man halt einfach direkte Bank-Überweisungen machen, aber das ist leider auch aus technischen Gründen, also weil Mangopay das so vorgibt, keine Entscheidung von Flatter, muss man jetzt sozusagen sich für jede Transaktion immer wieder einen neuen Kommentar, sozusagen so ein Hash-Value, der in dieser Überweisung mit drin ist, übergeben. Also man kann jetzt immer noch keine recurring payments machen, man könnte jetzt keinen Dauerauftrag machen, um da Geld einzuzahlen, aber immerhin geht es sozusagen schon mal über die Bank. Da sind sie ja wohl irgendwie hinterher, mal gucken, ob das auch bald noch kommt, aber insofern, it's not dead yet. Ja, das kann man glaube ich festhalten.
Das ist auf jeden Fall sehr erfreulich, ja. Also ich hoffe auch, dass, dass gerade mit diesem direkten Geld hin und her schicken, vielleicht doch auch ein paar Leute wieder Bock drauf haben, weil ich schon oft auch so gehört habe, dass das viel abgestreckt hat. Also gerade jetzt zur Weihnachtszeit haben einige Hörer auch mal gefragt, ich habe ja keinen Flatter hier wegen und kann man dir sonst noch irgendwie was zukommen lassen als kleinen Support? Und ja, ich hoffe mal, dass das jetzt vielleicht doch nochmal dazu führt, dass wieder ein paar Leute mehr Bock auf Flatter haben, weil ich habe jetzt für die Steuererklärung 2014, die ich jetzt noch kurz vor Jahresende 2015 eingereicht habe, habe ich auch nochmal die Flatter-Einnahmen und so begutachtet und da war 2014 auf jeden Fall auch echt, also ist jetzt im kleinen Rahmen, aber es war schon ein deutlicher Unterschied zwischen zum Beispiel diesem Jahr und das hat bestimmt auch mit diesem Instacast zu tun, aber bestimmt auch mit dieser Umstellung auf Skrill Only, weil ich glaube schon, dass zwar nicht alle PayPal haben, aber schon noch die allermeisten wurden gegen dieses Skrill, also dieser ganze Anmeldeprozess, das ganze UI und so, das war einfach die Hölle. Also das wollte ich auch nicht benutzen, aber musste es benutzen, um an das Geld zu kommen. Und ja, ich hoffe, es wird alles besser werden.
Genau, es gibt natürlich jetzt auch noch Probleme. Ich habe das zum Beispiel mal ausprobiert und habe versucht, so eine Banküberweisung auch mal anzustoßen, um festzustellen, dass die Bank, bei der ich bin, Sparkasse... Barskasse?
Also du bist nicht bei einer Bank.
Das habe ich dann auch wieder gemerkt. Also vor kurzem haben sie mich schon damit terrorisiert, dass sie ein Überweisungslimit gemacht haben. Ich meine, ich weiß auch, warum sie das machen, weil sie da einfach ein Fraudproblem haben, dem sie versuchen, irgendwie Herr zu werden in diesem ganzen SEPA-Business. Das heißt, sie haben jetzt erstmal die Überweisungsmengen begrenzt, ich glaube auf 3000 Euro und wenn man mal irgendwo 6000 oder 7000 Euro überweisen will, dann muss ich dann irgendwie auf der Webseite für 24 Stunden mein Limit hochsetzen und so. Und war mir auch neu. Konnte ich dann aber immerhin selber tun. Hat auch funktioniert. Soweit schon mal ganz gut. So, dann habe ich aber das jetzt mit Flatter probiert.
Du hast aber keine Wartezeit oder so. Das heißt, derselbe Typ, der jetzt dein Banking-Account gehackt hat über die Webseite, kann sich selber das Limit hochsetzen, sofort sein Zeugs nach Russland überweisen und dann ist es jetzt voll die Vorprävention. Hab ich jetzt richtig verstanden. Also, was ich gerne auch verstehen würde, ist, wenn man das jetzt hochsetzen müsste und dann giltet erst ein paar Stunden später und dann ruft dich unten ein Vogel an oder sie schickt dir eine SMS oder so. Aber über den selben Mechanismus, über den du dir die Kohle überweist, kannst du auch dein Limit hochsetzen. Also Security-Theater.
Dann bin ich auf heute auf jeden Fall auf was anderes gestoßen. Nämlich, dass dieser Bankkontakt von Flatter ist, Luxemburg.
Das würde ich auch sagen.
Das sind hier afrikanische Verhältnisse.
Und dann sagt mir irgendwie meine Überweisungs-Software, dass der HBCI-Server sich da gerade beschwert und meint, hier Luxemburg, nö.
Wo kommt man denn da hin?
Da haben die jetzt einfach mal alle Länder irgendwie geblacklisted, bzw. nur Deutschland ist gewidelisted.
Das hört sich nach einem europäisch einheitlichen Banking- und Währungssystem an.
Genau, ich habe sie da irgendwie angerufen heute und meinte so, ja, hier Luxemburg, hallo, Sepal, was stand das eh nicht für Europa und so?
Was eine laube Sepal!
Ja, also wenn sie ja geschäftlich das brauchen, dann können wir ihnen ja das auch dauerhaft freischalten.
Vielleicht möchte sie einfach nur deiner Freundin in Luxemburg was zukommen lassen.
Es ist halt einfach Fraud Prevention. Ich meine, da haben sie wahrscheinlich Recht, dass einfach 99,99% ihrer Kunden einfach nicht Geld nach Luxemburg überweisen normalerweise.
Deswegen ist es auch so wichtig, dass Sepal eingeführt wird und dass jetzt die I-Bahn-Nummer auch erzwungen wird. Endlich! Ab 1. Januar kannst du, darfst du uns verrecken, keine Kontonummer und Bankleitzahl mehr benutzen. Du wirst sofort erschossen. Stand rechtlich.
Hätte man sich nur noch um einen Standard benutzen, wo die I-Bahn-Nummer auch ausreicht, um eine Überweisung zu machen.
Gut ja auch, weil sie enthält ja zum Beispiel auch die Deutschen.
Nein, nur die Deutschen.
Nein, auch in anderen Ländern. In anderen Ländern ist es sogar so, da enthält die Kontonummer schon deine Bankinformation. Zum Beispiel in Schweden oder in Niederlande. Da brauchst du nämlich gar keine Bankinformation.
Die IBAN sollte das ja auch tun, trotzdem musst du ja diese BIC noch mit eingeben. Also du musst sozusagen nochmal eine redundante Information angeben, die noch auch nichts anderes ist als ein kryptischer String. Und da hätte man es ja eigentlich auch bei einem kryptischen String belassen können. Aber meines Wissens kannst du nur in Deutschland die Bankleitzahl aus einer, also aus einer alten Bankverbindung deine IBAN und BIC Nummer errechnen lassen. Und das geht in anderen Ländern nicht so ohne Weiteres.
In anderen Ländern, die diese Bankleitzahlen gar nicht haben.
Ja, was haben die denn dann?
Die haben einen eindeutigen Nummernkreis für Kontonummern, wie ich schon sagte, in Holland. Zumindest war das früher in Holland so.
Ja gut, aber dann kannst du doch daraus immer, dann kannst du aber trotzdem eine BIC draus berechnen.
Guck mal, Webseiten dafür. Du musst mal gucken, ich such dir mal eine schwedische IBAN raus und probieren wir das mal aus. Ach komm.
Schweden ist auch nicht ganz Europa.
Aber anyway.
Ich hatte das Problem auch schon beobachtet bei Kollegen, die bei der Deutschen Bank sind und ins polnische Ausland überweisen wollten. Das ging von der Berliner Volksbank aus problemlos. Und bei der Deutschen Bank war das auch erstmal nicht möglich. Da habe ich auch erstmal gestutzt, ist das jetzt, weil die vielleicht irgendwie jetzt nicht deutsche Staatsbürger sind? Wir haben ja da viele Leute aus der ganzen Welt und hat jetzt die Deutsche Bank da erstmal gleich alles so abgeriegelt. Aber selbst wenn du als Engländer, also...
Der ich eigentlich nicht bin.
Wenn du selbst bei der Sparkassade das nicht machen kannst, dann ist das ja wirklich ein bisschen scheuert.
Naja, mit KOM direkt ging es dann. Jetzt bin ich gespannt, wie lange es dauert, bis das auch durchschlägt.
Also, Flatter zusammenfassend, Good News, alles wird besser, neuer Skrill ist raus, PayPal immer noch raus, und man kann es jetzt direkt machen, ja?
Ach, direkt.
Kreditkarten und Bankverbindungen nehmen. Wobei, wenn du mal schaust, da steht dann sozusagen dabei, ähm...
Und man kann es nur an eine Bank verwenden, man kann es nicht irgendwo hin überweisen, richtig? Das dürfen die nämlich nicht. Ich darf dann nur mich eintragen als Empfänger von Geld. Nicht irgendwen. Ich kann mein Flattergeld nicht an dich überweisen, wenn ich wollte. Ja, genau. Man trägt da so eine Adresse ein, und das ist meine, und die bleibt auch dann immer so.
Da die Funktion jetzt noch gesperrt ist, kann ich dir ehrlich gesagt über die Funktion nicht so seltsam sagen.
Ja, nee, dann wären sie ja wieder eine Bank, wenn man das auch an andere überweisen könnte. Man kann das nur an sich selbst zurück überweisen.
Und das spürst du einmal koderdadurch, flatterst irgendwie in dein zweiter Account und überweist es wieder quer durch die Gegend.
Ja, kann ich mir ja jetzt vorstellen. Weiß ich aber nicht, wie das jetzt genau laufen wird.
Das ist ja auch nicht der Kern des Brudels jetzt bei der ganzen Sache.
Sofortüberweisung haben sie drin, ja.
Wow, top. Ich muss auch nochmal hinzufügen, wir hatten glaube ich das Thema Flatter hier vor zwei, drei Monaten mal.
Wir haben das immer mal wieder.
Ja, aber da hatten wir das glaube ich noch mal ein bisschen ausführlicher besprochen. Und da haben wir auch, hab ich glaube ich auch mal darauf hingewiesen, dass das sozusagen hier nach wie vor ein ganz wichtiger Beitrag ist. Und seitdem sind dann auch die Einnahmen auch wieder gestiegen, mit anderen Worten. Es ist einfach mal wichtig, darauf hinzuweisen. Und jetzt war es auch nochmal wichtig, dass sich die Gesamtsituation bei Flatter technisch verbessert. Und ich hoffe, dass das jetzt der Fall ist. Und wenn es jetzt noch technische Probleme gibt, bin ich mir auch relativ sicher, dass das so in der nächsten Woche dann alles überwunden sein wird.
Im Jahresende läuft das.
Ich finde auch, dass eigentlich immer ganz charmant bei den Leuten, die halt nicht Werbung machen oder sonst irgendwelche komischen, ja, weiß nicht, scheinheiligen Einnahmekonzepte haben, sondern einfach gelegentlich mal darauf hinweisen, hier, wenn euch der Content gefällt und ihr meine Mark übrig habt oder ein Euro, dann ab dafür. Ich habe zum Beispiel auch so einen YouTube-Kanal von so einem Musiker bei YouTube abonniert oder subskribiert und der macht echt viele Videos und auch ganz viele so quasi Gitarrenunterricht gratis und macht auch wirklich cooles Zeug und der sagt zum Beispiel auch immer so, wenn es euch gefällt hier, da Paypal-Adresse, also ich freue mich über einen Dollar oder so und wenn ihr keinen Dollar habt, auch cool, lasst uns mal Gitarre spielen. Also so ganz entspannt und jetzt nicht so, ja, hier, also Leute, die nicht aufs Werbebanner klicken oder die Werbeblocker benutzen, scheiße. Leute, die, und so weiter, also es gibt ja auch so eine Kandidatin, da finde ich jetzt auch so diesen generellen Podcaster-Ansatz hier, den wir alle so schätzen und vorleben mit der ganz entspannten Haltung schon auf jeden Fall ganz nett und sympathisch. Deswegen, hin und wieder kann man das ruhig mal sagen, dass man sich über so flatter Freud in deinem Fall auch darüber finanziert.
Was wir hiermit getan haben. Bleiben wir beim Geld.
Jetzt aufwachen, Dennis.
Der Geldchef ist gefunden jetzt, ist endlich alles rauf.
Ja, nee, wir haben uns noch aus Australia gefunden, aber irgendwie, wenn ich das jetzt, ich habe es noch nicht nachgebracht.
Kurz nochmal den Hintergrund erklären. Also, Bitcoin wurde mal erfunden von Satoshi Nakamoto.
Von einem Typen, dessen Synonym Satoshi Nakamoto war. 2009 Anfang hat er auf diese Mailingliste und diesen Pseudonym geschrieben. Und seitdem hat er noch ein bisschen mitgemacht, ist danach aber untergetaucht und ist auch nicht mehr aktiv beim Entwickeln von Bitcoin dabei. Und die suchen ihn jetzt natürlich andauernd, weil alle würden natürlich gerne wissen, wer das ist. Und wir haben auch schon mehrere Typen durch, unter anderem so einen armen Rentner in Los Angeles, der es aber noch nicht gewesen ist, aber auch so heißt. Und dann der Vielversprechendste war ein Typ, der Nick Xabo heißt, so ein Mathe-Professor aus sonst wo, der glaube ich aber auch in den USA lebt und der auch schon viel mit Kryptowährungen gemacht hat. Der es aber auch wohl nicht sein soll, aber da wäre ich mir immer noch nicht so sicher. Er ist auf jeden Fall vielversprechend. Und jetzt haben sie halt wieder einen anderen gefunden, irgendeinen Australier, der auch mehrere Doktortitel und Zeug hat und Firmen, die auch sich viel mit Bitcoin beschäftigen. Und jetzt meinen sie, der wär's. Und der würde es auch immer so ein bisschen behaupten. Aber ich hab das jetzt nicht toll nachgelesen, aber das ist mehr oder weniger schon total in der Luft auseinandergenommen und da muss man nicht weiter hinterher googeln.
Wann fand ich, dass sie innerhalb von Stunden, nachdem sie das Gerücht zu seiner Runde macht, erstmal richtig fett mit Polizei und Tralala angereist sind? Ja, aber das war wohl wegen einer anderen Geschichte. Ja, ja, ja, rein zufällig. Gerade jetzt, Stunden nachdem sie das Gerücht und muss jetzt gerade mal wegen einer Steuerfahndungssache mal bei ihm die Polizei vorbeikommen und das Haus auseinanderschrauben.
Ja, aber ein Haus, in dem er auch schon wohl länger nicht mehr drin wohnt, also der ist da gar nicht mehr. Und so, auch seine Accounts, die bei Facebook sind wohl, waren erst gesperrt. Inzwischen sind sie schon ganz gelöscht. Also das ist alles Mumpitz. Also, lasst mal über Bitcoin reden und nicht über den. Und bei Bitcoin passiert gerade ein kleiner Wechsel. Und zwar haben die mit der Version 0.11.2 eine neue Block-Version eingeführt. Und das ist ein sogenannter Soft Fork. Und die Regel ist, wenn die letzten 1000 Blöcke, die bei Bitcoin gefunden wurden, wenn die 95% davon die neue Version sind, ab dann wird die alte Version nicht mehr angenommen. Also das heißt, vorher gab es Version 3. Jetzt erzeugen schon ganz viele meiner Version 4. Und es gibt hier so eine Grafik, wo man sehen kann, was die Minimumzeit ist, in der die Umstellung stattfinden könnte. Nämlich dann, wenn alle nächsten Blöcke, die gefunden werden, auch Version 4 sind. Und das ist inzwischen auf vier Tage rund. Das heißt, in vier Tagen könnte es schon passieren, dass sie das wechseln. Das heißt, jeder, der dann noch nicht die neue Version von Bitcoin hat, der kann nicht mehr so richtig mitmachen. Also User, die glaube ich nur Überweisung machen, noch so halb, aber die Miner zum Beispiel, deren Blöcke würden dann nicht mehr angenommen werden.
Was heißt denn die neue Version?
Na, das ist das, was ich auch schon mal vor ein paar Folgen erzählt habe. Irgendwie ist da so ein neues... Also dieses Überweisen innerhalb von Bitcoin funktioniert ja mit so einer Art Skript. Also da ist so ein signiertes Skript, was ausführt, wohin die Inputs und die Outputs von deinen Bitcoins gehen. Also wenn ich dir was überweise, dann kommen meine Inputs, die ich irgendwann mal bekommen habe, dann gibt's Outputs zu dir. Und das Wechselgeld geht auch wieder zu mir zurück. Und das ist so ein kleines Skript, was das beschreibt. Und da haben die irgendwie ein neues Feature aufgenommen, wo man halt so time-based Überweisungen machen kann. Und mit Multisig, das wenn irgendwie nach, ja, nach sechs Monaten zum Beispiel, wenn das Geld nicht überwiesen ist, dann braucht man die, dann braucht man nicht mehr zwei Signaturen, sondern doch nur noch eine, damit man an sein Geld wieder rankommt. Aber solange vorher könnte man auch, geht das nur mit zwei Signaturen oder was anderes rum, irgendwie so. Also auf jeden Fall time-based. Und diese neuen Features, die muss man ja irgendwann durchdrücken, dass jeder kann. Und alle, die noch nur Version 3 beherrschen bei Bitcoin, die können diese Skripte halt nicht richtig bearbeiten. Und deswegen würde das nicht gehen. Und deswegen ist jetzt sozusagen die Zeit, wo die halt rausfliegen. Und das könnte aktuell in 4,6 Tagen passieren. Dann könnte die Umstellung stattfinden, frühestens, also im Minimum. Eher länger, aber es könnte. Und das ist eine Änderung bei Bitcoin. Also sollte man, wenn man da mal ordentlich mitmachen will, seinen Bitcoin-Client updaten. Und wenn man einen Node irgendwie auf seinem Server laufen hat, weil man Spaß an der Währung hat, einfach nur so, und den da laufen lässt, dann sollte man den auch irgendwie updaten.
Und was muss man dann sozusagen jetzt fahren für eine Version?
0.11.2. Ich finde, die haben diesen Change auch ein bisschen schnell gemacht, weil die Version ist so von 20. November rum, irgendwie ein bisschen vorher vielleicht. Und jetzt ist gerade mal der 10. heute oder was? Oder der 9. und jetzt ist es schon fast so weit mit dieser Umstellung. Es ist ein bisschen krass schnell, weil...
Ich auch, vor allem, wenn es die neue Software gibt. Mir hätte der da hier noch nicht gesagt, dass es die gibt.
Ja, auf FreeBSD gibt es Bitcoin im Port-System und der Typ hat sich noch nicht gekümmert. Das heißt, alle, die halt Bitcoin auf FreeBSD fahren, die haben jetzt nicht die neue Version. Und ich hab halt den Bitcoin-Pool, hatte auch noch die alte Wesen und bis gestern und musste da gestern mit Hilfe noch mal das alles umstellen, weil deren Bildsystem ist auch ein bisschen komisch.
Das Scheißteil sagt einem ja auch gar nicht Bescheid, dass es eine neue Version gibt.
Das macht das nicht.
Das ist so 20...
Das ist halt so multi-portable Software. Das ist halt Linux, FreeBSD, Windows und Zeug.
Wir müssen ja trotzdem Software-Update-Check machen. Das wird ja wohl unter den drei Bildsystemen irgendwie nicht kompetierbar sein. Nein, da müssen wir ja HTTP machen. HTTPS, bitte. Daran scheitert es wahrscheinlich. Wir konnten leider unsere Zertifikate nicht richtig überprüfen.
Eine Frage, die wir uns hier im Vorfeld der Sendung, bevor Hans hier erschienen...
Aber es ist noch nicht fertig.
Dann Hans entspanne ich gleich nochmal.
Ansonsten, bei Bitcoin fällt mir noch was ein.
Eigentlich ist da gar nichts mehr, aber warte, warte.
Außer, da kommt ja noch was anderes. Es gibt ja noch mehr mit Bitcoin. Außer, dass der Preis da gerade steigt, falls Leute das immer nicht mitkriegen und irgendwie ihre fetten Reserven in ihren Wallets haben und das nicht so wissen und mal Geld ausgeben wollen. Also ich würde sagen, jetzt gerade ist ein guter Zeitpunkt, das ist gut hochgegangen. Keine Garantie, dass das so bleibt. Könnte auch sein, das Ding wieder steigt oder weiter steigt, weiß man nicht, aber es ist auf jeden Fall nicht schlecht.
Anlageberatung der Adelle Zahrens! Alter, bis morgen, ich also!
Vielleicht auch Regen.
Oder es ändert sich, ich weiß.
Was passiert im Gegensatz zu den letzten Tagen, als es wieder angezogen ist, muss man ja wissen.
Aber wer größere Bitcoin-Reserven hat und nicht über den Preis informiert ist, der hat es auch nicht verdient.
Das ist auch schon substanziell höher als der letzte Spike, abgesehen von dem Ultra-Spike, der kurzfristig nur für mich durchgeführt wurde.
Ja, dein Spitzenverkauf.
Mein Spitzenverkauf, 500 Euro.
Aber du hast dich wieder eingekauft, richtig? Siehste, hat dir also nichts genützt. Okay, die anderen News ist, es gibt ja immer noch diese, mein Lieblings-Bitcoin-Startup, diese Bitwalla-Firma. Und bei denen kann man jetzt auch per Bitcoin auf ein Paypal-Konto überweisen, um das direkt zu machen, um das nicht von seinem Konto zu machen, oder von Bitcoins über das eigene Konto und dann wieder zu Paypal, sondern das geht jetzt direkt. Und dann noch Top Secret News, ich hoffe, ich erzähle jetzt nicht zu viel, weil es hat er mir letzte Woche halb im Suff beim Room 77 erzählt, gibt es demnächst von Bitwaller eine Kreditkarte, die man mit Bitcoins aufladen kann. Also eine Bitwaller Kreditkarte sozusagen.
Und dann?
Also eine Prepaid-Karte, da ist halt nix drauf und ist durch nix gedeckt und schiebst du mit Bitcoin, sagst du hier 500 Euro, in Bitcoins zahlst du und dann hast du dir auf deiner Prepaid-Kreditkarte und kannst sie halt ausgeben. Prepaid-Kreditkarten gibt es ja schon ohne Ende, das ist ja auch Standard inzwischen.
Prepaid-Kreditkarten.
Sind die dann überhaupt Kredit, wenn die Prepaid sind?
Also Kredit und Prepaid, also ich meine, da spricht sich ja direkt...
Ja, aber du weißt Visa halt, Prepaid-Visakarten.
Normalerweise ist ja Visa so, die sammeln das für einen Monat und dann ziehen sie das von deinem Konto ab, aber es gibt ja irgendwie, diese Prepaid wurde erfunden, weil Leute sind ja nicht vertrauenswürdig, weil eventuell ist deren Konto halt nicht mehr voll. Also musst du die vorbezahlen, Prepayen, von mir aus. Aber Debitkarten sind ja wiederum diese EC-Karten, oder nicht, wo das direkt abgezogen wird. Das ist ja auch nicht so richtig. Du lädst ja vorher auf die Karte.
Ja, aber es wird ja auch dann von deinem Konto abgezogen, was du vorher aufgeladen hast.
Aber es ist trotzdem eine Visa, Mastercard, American Express.
Ja, aber es ist keine Creditcard, in dem Sinne, wo du Kredit kriegst.
In Deutschland ist die Creditcard alles als dieses größte Format.
Dem Kassierer ist das scheißegal, ob die Prepaid ist, oder ob die credited ist. Ja, nicht ganz. Aber letztendlich, wenn da das Visa-Logo drauf ist, fragt dich jetzt erstmal keiner, ob die Prepaid ist.
Bezahlvorgang ist dann nachher schon der gleiche. Das ist egal, ob Prepaid oder nicht. Das ist das gleiche Bezahlvorgang, wenn ich die dann benutze, nur wie ich sie auflade oder wie Visa das abrechnet, ist was anderes. Okay, jedenfalls von Bitwalla wird es dann wahrscheinlich auch demnächst so Prepaid Creditcards geben. Was noch interessant, weil ich erzähle das jetzt mal einfach, ich war ja letzten Donnerst wieder bei diesen Bitcoin-Treffen.
Das heißt, dass man mit dieser Karte quasi überall kaufen kann, wo ich auch gemeinhin mit der LC-Karte komme?
Das ist eine normale Creditcard, du lädst sie halt nur mit Bitcoins auf. Wenn du sie erstmal aufgeladen hast, dann hat das nichts mehr mit Bitcoins zu tun.
Okay, und wenn ich aber jetzt dann sozusagen im Supermarkt damit bezahle, dann wird mir das zu einem aktuellen Umrechnungskurs quasi in die Karte.
Nein, deine Euros sind dann schon längst drauf. Du besorgst ja heute die Karte, schiebst per Bitcoin 500 Euro drauf, dann sind da 500 Euro auf deiner Karte und dann kannst du die nächsten Tage losgehen und sie ausgeben.
Das ist nur die Transitwährung.
Genau. Diese Bitwaller-Jungs, die haben mir erklärt, was sie halt nicht machen dürfen, weil sie eben keine Bank sind. Die dürfen kein Geld direkt liegen haben, sondern sie müssen immer in die Bitcoins reinkommen. Die müssen sofort weiterwandern. Sie dürfen keine User-Content mit Kohle haben. Und in diesem Fall wandert das Geld sozusagen gleich an Visa weiter auf so eine Kreditkarte und deswegen können sie das machen. Das ist der einzige Grund, warum die überhaupt ihren Start-up haben. Weil sie halt eben kein Geld da liegen haben, weil sie keine Bank sind. Sonst würde das nicht gehen. Das war jetzt das andere, was mich unterbrochen hat. Das weiß ich jetzt auch nicht mehr. Das kommt jedenfalls demnächst.
Geht der Preis wieder hoch irgendwie?
Der wird immer hochgehen. Wenn nicht, dann haben wir Pech gehabt.
Aber ich behaupte, der geht hoch. Die besten Investment-Tipps allerhand.
Also die Frage ist genauso groß wie die Antwort. Das weiß man halt einfach nicht. Ich meine persönlich, ich setze darauf, dass das höher geht. Ich weiß natürlich, was ich erzählen wollte. Und zwar war bei diesem Bitcoin-Treffen im Room 77, kam auch ein Visa, ein Typ von Visa. Und da habe ich ihn gefragt, ob er halt privat oder beruflich da ist. Er meinte tatsächlich, er ist beruflich da. Sein Bier würde theoretisch von seinem Chef bezahlt werden, aber er zahlt es halt mal selber, weil es ist wahrscheinlich zu komplex mit dem Abrechnen. Aber er ist ja tatsächlich beruflich da. Und die machen jetzt hier von Visa, weil die sehen ja irgendwie die ganzen Banken, wenn man das ja online so liest, finden halt die Blockchain geil. Die Blockchain ist gerade das neue Cloud, jedenfalls für Banken. Und die sehen da halt mit der Blockchain irgendeine Technologie, mit der anscheinend Bitcoin funktioniert. Und sie wollen die auch gerne nutzen, diese Technologie, diese Blockchain-Technologie. Und so, wie ich das aber durchhöre, sehen sie halt da so eine technologische Lösung. Und sie forschen jetzt nach dem Problem, was sie damit lösen könnten. Aber sie finden es nicht, weil das Problem sind sie halt selbst.
Wie sie suchen nach der Frage, zu der sie die Antwort haben? Wo kenne ich das bloß her?
Genau, was mir erklärt wird, wenn so dieser Zeitarbeiter oder irgendwie so ein Arbeiter in London ist, der eigentlich aus Südamerika kommt und da arbeitet und Geld zurück zu seiner Familie nach Südamerika schicken wollte, das war sein Beispiel, dann Visa kann ja sowas nicht machen, das ist ja nicht deren Business, so. Aber der Arbeiter könnte dann dort in London per Visa ein Bitcoin zahlen, das Bitcoin zahlt das dann nach Südamerika und da kann seine Mom das dann von Bitcoin wieder in Richtung Visa machen, habe ich mir aufgeregt. Aber, wozu braucht ihr dann ein Bitcoin? Ihr könnt doch einfach so ein... Ihr habt dann eine DB, macht ihr da 100 Euro oder 100 Dollar minus und da 100 Dollar plus und fertig oder andersrum.
Oder wozu braucht ihr Visa?
Eben, ihr könnt doch einfach so einen afghanischen Western Union Typen, also die machen die seit Jahren so, dass die da an wenige Orte geben.
Ich habe mich auch erkannt, da braucht man keinen Bitcoin, aber wie gesagt, wir sehen halt Bitcoin, also Blockchain, nicht Bitcoin, Blockchain ist für die die Technologie und sie suchen jetzt das passende Problem, was sie damit fixen können.
Also auf gut deutsch, er hatte keine Ahnung.
Würde ich fast so sagen, aber das ist halt bei allen Banken so.
Kennst du das Video hier?
Don't understand Bitcoin. This man will mumble and explanation to you.
Das ist gut. Mach mal in den Chat.
Hab ich im Chat gepastet.
Ist das so ein Generierter oder? Das gibt es ja auch, diese beiden geretteten und die da immer so stehen, der Teddy und der andere.
Wir spielen das jetzt live ein hier. Wer ist denn der Typ erstmal?
Öffentlichen Plattform, den Blockchain, anbieten.
Da es eine öffentliche Rekorde ist, weiß jeder, dass Bitcoins mit einem zugehörigen Konto sind und jemanden von dem Geld, der nicht in den Händen ist, verhindern. In den ganzen Tagen hat man Banken, die sich für Geld halten, und dann kann man sie auflocken, um zu verhindern, dass Bananen nicht aussteigen.
Komm mit Sachs, Faisal, auch wenn du ein Winkle-Boss-Twin bist.
Kunden wollen immer Linux und da muss ich immer dieses verfilzte... Und das Allergeilste ist wirklich, das Allerschönste Linux ist ja Centos, weil Centos ist ja total sicher. Von Red Hat. Und das kommt mit SeeLinux und mit Firewall Enabled und so weiter. Default, Secure Default. Und ich hatte also noch nicht viele Viren. Einmal unter Windows oder einmal oder zweimal. Und jetzt inzwischen dreimal unter Linux. Da von zweimal auf frisch installierten Centos-Installationen. Centos installiert, Apache installiert, irgendwie Web-Server drauf, weggegangen, wieder hingekommen. Buh, irgendwie komisches Root-Kit drauf.
Ja.
In einer offiziellen Linux-Distribution?
Ja, also die Chinesen sind gut. Die machen mal so ein Ding so einfach auf. Also ich hab da nicht wirklich irgendwas installiert. Das geht schnell. Ja, aber Seedlinux ist so, es funktioniert nicht. File not found, permission denied. Und dann bist du wieder am Konfigurieren und nach fünf Mal hast du keine Lust mehr.
Dann schlägst du die Chinesen mal trotzdem drauf.
Das ist total sinnfrei. Also FreeBSD finde ich immer noch sehr gut, aber ich muss zugeben, dass ich doch nicht mehr viel nutze. Aber ich habe ja jetzt hier einen Macintosh seit einer Jahrzeit und deswegen...
Bist du dem BSD wieder näher?
Da kann ich Ctrl-T in der Shell drücken.
Bist du immer noch so ein TCS-H-Fan?
Nee, ich bin auf ZS-H gewechselt.
ZS-H, Lächer der Welt.
Ja, irgendwann musste ich...
Das mit dem Ctrl-T hast du mir irgendwann mal im Club beigebracht, weiß ich noch genau. Dass man bei DD dann auch mittendrin immer wieder Ctrl-T klicken kann.
Nee, aber ein Terminal-Driver-Feature.
Was kann man denn das mal dekodieren? Was kann man wann, wo, bei, wie?
Ergib mal Cut ein in deiner Schild, Cut, C-A-T, Enter. Ja, die Linuxer, die haben es natürlich. Und jetzt machen wir Ctrl-T.
Ctrl-T.
Und das ist nicht etwa das Cut, was dir was sagt, oder das Schnell-Driver, was dir was sagt, sondern es ist der Terminal-Driver, der dir das sagt.
Also für die Leute, die mir jetzt nicht gerade über die Schulter zugeschaut haben, die können das ja auch alle am Rechner machen. zeigt einem das System in dem Moment die LOD an. Und kannst du aus der LOD was rauslesen?
Nee, aber du kannst jetzt mal Ctrl-C eingeben und gib mal DD ein. Und Enter. Und dann nochmal Ctrl-T. DD läuft jetzt und will jetzt von deinem Standard innen nach deinem Standard out. Und DD hat einen eigenen Händler für, wie heißt das Signal?
Status. Gibt's einen Signal dafür, der in dem Prozess, wenn du diese Taste drückst, gibt's ja so diverse, wenn du den traditionellen Ctrl-C drückst, dann gibt's halt ein SigInt und Ctrl-Backslash, was heutzutage kaum noch uns jemand tippen kann.
Das gab's aber früher, nicht Six-Status.
Das gibt's schon ewig.
Nein.
Und das gab es sogar schon in VMS.
Da war es geklaut. Und in 4.3 BSD haben sie es in den Thermaletreiber eingebaut.
Das ist schon ewig, ja. Das ist schon ewig und drei Tage drin.
Guck mal, Timme, du warst hier in Wim, den Groß J einen beigebracht, mit der Zeile zusammenfügen und bei Hans Hübner, da weiß ich, er hat mir dieses Kontroll-T beigebracht.
SIG-Status.
Ja, das ist richtig Geheimwissen.
Und immer noch.
SIG-Status oder SIG-Stat?
SIG-Stat oder SIG-Stat-Status?
SIG-Stat oder SIG-Status.
Also was jetzt? Hier, Mr.. Wenn du da irgendwie einen Signalnamen greppen willst, dann musst du dich in die Kernessourcen begeben oder in irgendein Unterdirektor, in das Unterdirektor. Ja, ja, da geht das. Das ist auch so ein, warum ich hier bin.
Das ist aber jetzt auch mit dem SIG-Status, die folgt auf dem Mac, oder? Als wir das damals gemacht haben, haben wir das in die Shake oder so.
Das gibt's nicht, Leute.
Das gibt's nicht. Also der TTY-Charakter heißt Status und ich glaube, das könnte SIG-Info sein.
Hacker Nummer 5 hier. SIG-Status gibt's nicht.
Das hat Clemens gesagt. Clemens ist Hacker Nummer 4 im Übrigen, ne?
War echt klasse, neulich. Also bei der Der Wurzhafs Väter saß ich ja bei Dennis auch und Hans kam dann vorbei und saß, hey, hallo und wie geht es? Haben wir ein bisschen geplaudert. Und als er dann abhaut, meinte Dennis so, du kennst Hans? Woher kennst du Hans schon?
Ich sagte, hallo.
Er hat nie gesagt, dass er mal im Klub war oder so.
Nie. Die beiden haben doch hier die Bits nach Berlin getragen. So ist das. Also, Ctrl-T ist SIG-Info.
Ja, SIG-Info, sag ich doch.
Ja, nicht SIG-Status.
Aber ich hab doch eben schon SIG-Info vorgelesen.
Ja, die musstet euch korrigieren. Und nicht hier mich so angucken.
20 Jahre keine Ahnung gehabt.
Du wehst du wieder nicht, wa?
Der Punkt geht jetzt voll an dich, Thomas.
Ich hab meine Signale gelernt. Ich hab ja monatelang als Kind bei euch da in deiner Bude rumgehangen und einen ganzen Tag RFCs gelesen.
Hast du gemacht.
Ja, 90. Klar, da hab ich irgendwie UNIX gelernt bei euch. Also im Internet hab ich da gelernt. UNIX kannte ich schon vorher, aber ich bin da hingegangen und dann hattet ihr eine Festplatte, wo alle RFCs drauf waren. Vor allem gab es keinen Ort, wo man die jetzt so hätte ohne so weiteres haben können. Da war einfach ein Directory, da waren diese RFCs drin und ich hab den ganzen Tag, wie hieß die Bude? NetCS, hab ich bei euch gesessen und hab diese Dinger gelesen.
Ich hab das übrigens auch damals gemacht, weil es war nämlich mal Doku, die einfach mal frei verfügbar war. War damals noch totally unheard of, diese ganzen Anna-Quack, was Hans vorhin sagte, mit dem Datex-P, über diese X25-Standards, diese ETU-Standards, die gab es damals nur als Blue Book zu kaufen oder als Buch zu kaufen, was unglaublich teuer war. Diese blauen Dinger oder Green Book oder Red Book und so diese Dinger und die waren scheiße teuer. X25 ist ja auch nicht so dick, was hat das Ding 100 Seiten vielleicht, die habt 120 oder so, das hat über 100 Marke kostet damals so ein Ding und das fand ich mit diesen RFCs auch totally unheard und hab die auch eingesaugt, wie sie alle da waren, weil das war halt einfach mal freie Doku.
Die war auch tatsächlich lesbar.
Das kommt auch schwer hinzu.
Ich war nicht so geschmeidig.
Das liegt auch daran, dass die ATU Leute immer noch auf 350 andere Dokumente verweisen, die man wieder kaufen kann.
Da kann man auch sagen, wer sich mehr solche Geschichten anhören mag, wie damals das mit dem Internet und so war. Dieses Internet und die Hacker, die Sendung fand ich auch echt ganz gut in der Hinsicht.
100, ja.
Die andere war 84 oder so, oder?
Die hat schon Spaß gemacht.
Opa erzählt vom Krieg.
Genau, das wiederholen wir jetzt hier nicht alles. Aber ich meine, hier so mit Hacker Nummer 4 und Hacker 5, ich meine, ich übertreibe mir das auch nicht unbedingt so sehr, oder?
Weil man nur wie 1, 2 und 3 ist.
Na ja, du hast ja vorhin irgendwie Captain Crunch mit dazu gezählt. Das ist ja dann sozusagen schon außerhalb Deutschlands. Ich bezog mich jetzt eigentlich eher auf Deutschland.
Hans nicht. Es gab vor mir Hacker und es gibt nach mir Hacker. Was soll ich, also das ist doch so.
Ja, na ja, also ich meine, damals war halt schon so, weiß ich nicht, es gab halt hier ein paar und da ein paar und dann gab es halt in Berlin, da gab es halt Hans.
Oliver Laumann ist auf alle Fälle zu erwähnen, wenn man so Hacker in einstelligen Bereich sieht, sehen möchte. Der hat nämlich Screen geschrieben. Der hat mit Carsten Bohrmann in einem Zimmer in der Franklinstraße gesessen und in dem Zimmer hat neben Carsten und Oliver haben da, hat da noch eine eine VME-Bus 68.020-Maschine mit zwei Igel-Festplatten gehoused in diesem Zimmer. Ja, da war BSD 4.3 drauf.
4.2.
4.2. Und diese, also bei diesen Festplatten, da muss man wissen, die waren ungefähr 60, 70 Zentimeter tief und dann so 30x30 Zentimeter groß.
Und die Motoren, die da drinnen waren, die waren auch entsprechend groß es war sehr laut. Es war wirklich sehr, sehr laut. Aber Carsten Bohrmann hat Screen geschrieben und das war damals, das war der totale Bringer, weil du normalerweise, Oliver Laumann hat schon, ein Terminal, 80x25, dünner Kanal zu deinem Rechner und wenn du denn... Ist ja egal, aber wenn du irgendwie Make eingetippt hast, dann konntest du ja auf BSD immerhin Ctrl-Z drücken und das Ding zumindest mal anhalten und dann auch fortfahren. Aber wenn du noch was anderes tun wolltest und du hattest das halt gestartet, warst du halt gemeiert. Und Oliver hat dieses wunderbare Programm geschrieben, mit dem man dann zwei virtuelle Bildschirme haben konnte. Oder mehr.
Das nutze ich übrigens heute immer noch, gerade aktuell. Es hat nämlich inzwischen noch ein paar Leute übernommen, ich glaube Uni Erlangen.
Schon lange, ja.
Schon lange haben wir da rumgebastelt. Und das kann man sehr schön dafür benutzen, um so mehrere Leute an einer Stelle zu haben. Also das benutze ich heute noch, wenn ich zum Beispiel Leuten was fernkonfigure auf dem Router und sage aber, hallo, guck dir das mal mit an, dass sie dann sozusagen mir mit auf die Tastatur und wir zusammen auf dem Router rumhacken und so weiter.
Aber da kann ich auch mal sagen, also da hat sich auch in der Zwischenzeit was getan, also das TMUX ist schon noch mal eine Spur schicker auch.
Wieso ist es schicker? Jetzt machen wir den religiösen Krieg auf.
Nee, Freak Show Sendung Nummer, keine Ahnung, haben wir schon mal ausführlich besprochen, aber es hat einfach viele coole Features, die Screen zumindest meines Wissens nicht hat, aber das ist jetzt auch wieder so ein Thema.
Die Doku für Screen ist für einen Arsch. Ich kenne die TMUX-Doku nicht, aber die Doku für Screen ist halt einfach, weil das Ding unglaublich viele Optionen hat. Es ist halt schwer zu durchdringen. Aber funktional, glaube ich, steht TMUX nix nach.
Ich habe Screen den Rücken gekehrt, weil es meine Sessions aufgehängt hat. Und das konnte ich dann irgendwann nicht mehr akzeptieren und seitdem benutze ich TMUX. Aber auf alle Fälle ist, ich wollte ja eigentlich nur sagen, Oliver Laumann, der Autor von Screen, das ist sicherlich einer der ganz großen Helden der Berliner Computerszene und den würde ich natürlich auf jeden Fall als Hacker bezeichnen.
Gibt es den noch? Ich glaube, der ist auch noch in Bremen rum.
Ja, in Bremen und in Indien.
Ach, in Indien auch.
Na ja, jedenfalls ist er da viel. Das sieht man immer auf Twitter.
War der viel, viel älter als du noch oder deine Liga?
Fünf Jahre, sechs Jahre?
Älter?
Ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, ich habe das auch schon in diesem CRE gebracht, aber das muss ich jetzt auch noch mal fallen lassen. Aber du hast schon für mich auch so einen totalen Living the Future-Moment geliefert damals. Was so sehr im Kontext steht mit diesen ganzen, auch mit den Telekommunikationsrealitäten in Berlin. Wir hatten das ja vorhin schon so. Telefonieren in Berlin war ja im Wesentlichen kostenlos oder kostete eine Einheit und dann konnte man halt seine Verbindung so lange offen halten wie immer. Und dann bin ich mal zu dir gekommen, das war diese Wohnung.
Jorgstraße.
Genau. Das Zimmer war im Wesentlichen leer und bestand aus einem einzigen Terminal, an dem ein Modem hing und das war sozusagen dein Arbeitsplatz. Also wirklich nur so ein Terminal und dahinter einfach direkt Telekommunikation und der Rechner, auf dem man gearbeitet hat, war halt schon woanders.
Das war geil.
Ja, das war 88. Das war irre. Also das war einfach, ich meine, heute hängen sie irgendwie alle.
Hans hat schon damals Cloud Computing gemacht.
Ja, das war einfach Scherz, Computing.
Ich war aber auch paranoid und ich hatte auch keinen Drucker. Und alles, was ich an Aufzeichnungen hatte, habe ich mit einem Stift auf einen Zettel geschrieben. Und das hat dann dazu geführt, dass ich keine Festplatten hatte, die bei Hausdurchsuchungen mitgenommen werden konnten oder irgendwelche Listings oder irgendein Quark. Hatte ich alles nicht. Nur irgendwelche komischen Zettel, die ich mal vollgeschrieben habe. Und dann waren sie vollgeschrieben und kamen irgendwie weg. Ja, eine kriminelle Vergangenheit.
Naja, jetzt bist du ja ganz ordentlich.
Zu ordentlich für manchen.
Wie ich schon sagte, Establishment.
Als Spießer musste ich mich ja im CCC schon immer bestimpfen lassen.
Wie lange verheiratet warst du?
Ja, und zwei Kinder und alles und Scheiß.
Das hat sich ja auch alles geändert. Da hat ja jeder gefolgt. Immer noch die Nase voll.
Ja, Hans ist immer noch ganz weit vorne.
Ja, Tim, du bist erst bei zwei, ne?
Naja, ich hab mich schon auch immer direkt hinter Hans eingereiht.
Aber mit den Skates bist du vorausgefahren. Dann war ich noch unsportlich. Hätte mal früher angefangen.
Ja, aber wo wir gerade bei deinen alten Hackereien sind, mich würde ja nochmal so deine jüngsten Forschungsergebnisse im Bereich der Poemiersprachen interessieren, weil ich weiß, du hast dich mit einer ganz Mengen Sachen rumgeschlagen. Du hast ja schon immer eigentlich alles angeguckt. Wir hatten ja auch schon mal die Lisp-Sendung. Und das ist ja so ein Steckenpferd von dir. Aber du guckst ja auch sonst immer viel an. Was ist denn gerade so cool aus deiner Perspektive? Also was sind so, mit welchen von diesen Dingen, mit denen du dich beschäftigt hast, würdest du sagen, das war jetzt auch die Auseinandersetzung wert.
Ah naja, also ich meine, schon bei der Lisp-Sendung war es ja so, dass mein Enthusiasmus etwas gebremst war. Zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo du mich über Lisp befragt hast, da war ich schon etwas... Na ja, spoilt war ich. Ja, insofern, als wenn man einmal Lisp programmiert hat, dann will man eigentlich nichts Schlechteres mehr haben. Und da es nichts Besseres gibt, ist es dann schwer weiterzuleben. Das kenne ich gut. Es ist eben auch ein bisschen frustrierend mit dem Lisp. Ich habe dann eine Weile gedacht, na ja, jetzt kann ich auch mal Frontend lernen und habe dann ganz viel Node.js und Angular.js und Underscore und so einen Quark gemacht. Das ist aber auch nicht sehr befriedigend gewesen. Und dann habe ich jetzt die letzten paar Jahre Clojure gemacht und das macht relativ viel Spaß, weil es halt ein Lisp ist. Aber ein bisschen moderner als Common Lisp. Common Lisp stoppt so. Und hat so viel Baggage drin. Also alte Leute und alte Texte und so. Es ist ein bisschen wie Latein und ist auch nicht schlecht.
Das ist ja mal ein schöner Vergleich.
Aber es ist auch tatsächlich so. Man kann von Lisp immer noch viel lernen. Und es hat auch noch irgendwie so eine eindeutige... Dinge, die andere Sprachen eben einfach nicht haben. Aber es ist halt nicht sehr praktisch. Und fördert das Alleinsein. Also mit Lisp kann man sehr gerne sehr gut allein sein. Das ist für Clojure sicherlich auch... In Maaßen stimmt das für Clojure auch. Weil das auch ein Lisp ist. Und weil man da auch sehr viele expressive Freiheiten hat. Aber dadurch, dass das so neu ist, gibt es da auch so eine Community, die das so mitträgt. Und wo es so ein gemeinsames Verständnis gibt. In Common Lisp ist es so, dass diese Community nicht mehr richtig existiert. Sondern da lauter Einzelkämpfer sind. Und die alten Männer haben alle ihre Makros und ihre Welt und ihren Style. Und wenn man sich das dann anguckt und man schon mal was richtiges gesehen hat, was modernes, und sich dann anguckt, wie die programmieren, dann kann man einfach nur mit dem Kopf schütteln. So macht man das heutzutage. Die wissen nicht, was ein Test ist zum Beispiel. Das wissen die einfach gar nicht. Und dann kommt ein junger Mensch an und sagt, Test trifft Design. Und das ist heutzutage so ein No-Brainer. Und dann guckt sich so ein Lisp-Typ erstmal an. Und sagt, ich habe einen guten Kurs, die arbeiten alle in der gleichen Consulting-Firma. Und das erzeugt so eine gewisse komische Dynamik. Weil die halt so, die wollen halt ihr Ding machen. Und was die anderen machen, ist zwar auch ganz interessant und nette Community, aber es gibt sowas wie innen und außen. Und das ist so, das ist ein bisschen nervig. Aber als Sprache ist es sehr, sehr komfortabel. Und hat coole Features wie STM auf Sprachebene. Software Transactional Memory. Das sind Transaktionen im Hauptspeicher. Transaktionen sind ja eigentlich nur dann interessant, wenn man Sachen hat, die gleichzeitig laufen. Und wenn du parallel laufende Prozesse hast, dann ist es nützlich, dass du auf deinen Datenstand optimistisch operierst und dann sagst du, jetzt bin ich fertig damit und committe das mal. Und dann guckt das Laufzeitsystem für dich nach, ob jemand anders die gleichen Strukturen manipuliert hat. Und wenn das der Fall ist, dann rollt das Ganze zurück und dann kannst du retrain. Und das macht das Laufzeitsystem für dich halt automatisch. Also Memory-Transaktionen. Und das macht nur im Zusammenhang mit Parallelprogrammierung natürlich Sinn. Wenn du Sachen hast, die tatsächlich gleichzeitig laufen und nicht nur so gemultitast sind, aber das ist halt da somit eingebaut als Standardmechanismus.
Also wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel was weiß ich, so ein Tri von Daten hast, auf dem mehrere Prozesse gleichzeitig herumfuhrwerken, dann gehst du immer erstmal so ran mit, ich mach das jetzt mal so, als gäbe es keinen anderen, aber es gibt sozusagen Collision Detection, so wie bei Ethernet. Man merkt zumindest, wenn man gleichzeitig da in den Raum geschrien hat und dann kann es wieder gefixt werden, aber man verlegt es sozusagen nur auf diesen Ausnahmefall, damit man normalerweise einfach durchmarschieren kann.
Genau. Und was im Zusammenhang mit Clojure noch interessant ist, sind die funktionale Datenstrukturen. Also Datenstrukturen, die benutzen dafür das Wort Persistent. Und das ist ein bisschen misslich, weil Persistenz kennt man ja als Begriff für ist-auf-er-Fest-Platte. Die benutzen das aber für Immutable Data Structures. Und Immutable Data Structures sind so, dass wenn du eine Hashtable hast, und du hast einen Pointer auf dieser Hashtable, dann änderst du die, dann änderst du sie nicht wirklich, sondern änderst eine Kopie. Und dein Originalpointer zeigt immer noch deine konsistente, vorherige Version dieser Hashtable. Und das ist halt auch überall mit eingebaut, diese Immutable Data Structures. Und das ist angenehm damit zu arbeiten. Das ist ein angenehmes Umfeld mit nützlichen Datenstrukturen, die man so einfach benutzen kann wie Sets und Maps und Vektoren. Und Makros hat man halt auch. Es ist halt ein Lisp. Und damit programmier ich es seit einiger Zeit. Und das macht Spaß.
Und auch nicht nur zum Spaß an der Freizeit, sondern du realisierst da auch Dinge mit.
Ja, ich habe ja vorher 10 Jahre kommerziell Common Lisp gemacht. Und jetzt mache ich halt seit, weiß ich nicht, 2 Jahren, haben wir die meisten Sachen, die neuen Sachen, alle in Clojure gemacht. Und wenn ich keinen Bock mehr habe, dann höre ich damit auf. Also was Clojure halt nicht hat, und was sicherlich auch eine Sache ist, die mich stört, ist statisches Typ-System. Und statisches Typ-System und Lisp passt halt einfach nicht zusammen. Und wenn ich nochmal was anderes mache, dann mache ich mal irgendwas mit einem statischen Typ-System wieder. Ich war ja früher C++-Programmierer, und das hat auch so seine Meriten, weil man so ein bisschen...
Also doch Swift.
Nee, das... Ja, ich will keine Apple Desktop-Applikationen schreiben, und ich will auch nicht einen Apple als Server benutzen. Also irgendwie Swift ist für mich... Ja, läuft auch auf Linux.
Kommen wir ja gleich zu. Jetzt erklär doch erstmal kurz, warum die Vorzüge von statischen...
Na, statisches Typ-System... Also in dynamischen Sprachen hast du halt immer so eine Unsicherheit. Ist das, was ich jetzt hier gerade habe, tatsächlich das, was ich glaube, was es ist? Und du hast wenig Möglichkeiten, aus der statischen Code-Struktur das wirklich zu entnehmen, sondern am Schluss weißt du es erst, wenn das Programm läuft. Und dafür hat man halt heutzutage Tests, aber es ist eben so ein Ding... Also wenn du Code liest, dann kannst du diesen Code nicht unmittelbar... Geht da nicht wirklich die Korrektheit raus hervor, sondern das ergibt sich halt eigentlich oft erst aus dem Laufzeitverhalten. Und deswegen ist der Wunsch nach statischen Typen nicht ganz abwegig. Das finde ich irgendwie nicht total verwerflich, diesen Wunsch zu haben. In Lisp gibt es das aber nicht. Und es gibt dann Leute, die kreistern ihr Lisp mit Typikation zu. Das kann man dann nicht mehr lesen. Das macht auch überhaupt gar keinen Sinn und keinen Spaß. Aber für mich ist das so das, wo Lisp eben einfach nicht die richtige Sprache ist. Hab ich vielleicht sogar mal wieder was in C++ machen wollen. Aber mein letztes C++-Projekt war dann eben so ein 90er-Jahre-C++ und das macht halt auch keinen Spaß, wenn man alles immer extra hinschreiben muss.
Aber auf jeden Fall zu diesem Clojure, dieser Richecki, der hat auf dieser infoq.com-Seite, hat man auch schon mal verlinkt. Kann man ja auch noch mal sagen, der Typ an sich ist auf jeden Fall ziemlich smart und sehr charmant in der Erklärung auch von diesen ganzen coolen Features von Clojure. Und das kann man sich auf jeden Fall, egal ob man Klammern mag oder nicht, mal reinfahren und sich auf jeden Fall mal inspirieren lassen.
Simple made easy und The Language of the System sind die beiden Präsentationen von Richecki.
The Language of the System, die habe ich glaube ich noch nicht gesehen, aber ich würde jetzt auch noch die Functional Database, wollte ich jetzt auch nochmal hervorheben. Atomic? Naja, der Talk, der so heißt, The Functional Database, die sich dann auf Datomic bzw. auf die grundsätzliche Problematik, dass sein Tenor ist ja bei Clojure auch immer so dieses ganze Read-Write-Languages, die halt irgendwie die ganze Zeit wieder andere Werte in dieselbe Variable reinschreiben und so. Das bringt das ja alle nur in die Hölle. Hat er ja auch recht. Aber was hilft, wenn du jetzt sozusagen so eine Sprache hast, die das ordentlich macht, und dann verwendest du halt SQL und dann hast du sozusagen das Gleiche nochmal. Und denkt sozusagen dann eben dieses Konzept einer immutable Datenstruktur eben auch für die Datenbank, die sich eben auch nie ändert, sondern eigentlich so wie das bei Git ja auch der Fall ist, einfach immer nur mehr Daten anhäuft, aber eben jederzeit in jedem beliebigen alten Zustand herumvorwerken kann und von daher so stable Links hat. Ich fand das alles sehr überzeugend, wie er das übergebracht hat.
Also das ist halt der Punkt bei Ritschiki und auch bei Stu Holloway, also bei dieser Cognitech Guru Truppe ist, dass die sehr überzeugend rüberkommen und es leicht ist, da mehr drin zu sehen, als sie wirklich haben. Also die Technik, die die verkaufen, ist auch nichts Neues und die bedienen sich auch nur aus Papers, die sind teilweise irgendwie 20, 30 Jahre alt und das sagt Ritsch ja auch. Also es ist nicht so, dass die das verschleiern, aber die Präsentationstechnik, die die drauf haben, die macht halt, die lässt das alles neu erscheinen, was die erzählen und dann auch noch alles ganz toll. Und das birgt so ein bisschen die Gefahr, also wenn man da nicht aufpasst, also mir ist es zumindest so gegangen, dass ich oft den Fehler mache, wenn ich diese Präsentation sehe oder wenn ich mir von denen was anhöre, dass ich dann mehr erwarte, als es tatsächlich ist. Bei Datomic ist das zum Beispiel auch so. Datomic ist deren Datenbanksystem und das ist eben eine Immutable Database. Und das ist auch eine coole Sache. Also das ist insofern cool, als dass da das Gleiche passiert wie mit den In-Memory-Datenstrukturen. Wenn du einen Handle auf die Daten zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt X hast und danach passiert noch irgendwas, dann bleibt dein Handle vollständig valid und alles, was an diesem Handle dranhängt. Und das bedeutet für Datomic, dass du an jede beliebige Stelle in der Zeit zurückgehen kannst und sagen kannst, zeig mir doch mal wie die Datenbank da und da. Und dann heften die da das Label Time Travel dran. Und sagen, ja das ist Time Travel. Das kann man zwar so sagen, aber das ist nicht die ganze Wahrheit, weil man kann nicht in die Zeit zurückdrehen und die die die Geschichte ändern, sondern man kann nur zurückgehen und gucken, wie es da war. Und dann kann man halt in der Gegenwart kann man dann auch was Neues machen. Aber du kannst halt nicht, du kannst nicht forken, du kannst nicht irgendwas ändern, was damals war. Und das macht schon einen Unterschied, je nachdem wie man das präsentiert. Also im Prinzip ist das nicht Time Travel, sondern Universal History. Und du kannst halt, dadurch dass es eben, dass nichts gelöscht wird, kannst du die History an jeder Stelle recovern. Ja, das ist zwar richtig, aber das ist halt nur ein Feature. Und dafür musst du dir in Atomic eben alles andere selber bauen. Also alles, was man sonst so an Convenience-Features von Datenbanken hat, die ein bisschen mehr können als MySQL. Also ich meine, da kann man natürlich dann auch debattieren, welche Ansprüche man an der Datenbank haben soll und sollte und ob es überhaupt gut ist, dass Postgres Trigger und zwei Procedures und diesen ganzen Kram hat. Und vielleicht will man sowas ja gar nicht. So mag ja alles sein. Aber das ist letztlich die Competition von denen. Und da ist Datomic einfach, das liefert wirklich nur den Kern. Das ist so ein bisschen wie C-Isam früher. Also es ist irgendwie ganz, ganz, ganz cool, war C-Isam auch. Aber da fehlt eben dann noch ein ganzes, ein ganzer Middle Layer, der das Ganze auch benutzbar macht. Language of the System.
Und dann, aber einer, den fand ich ja noch fast besser, war ja über Entity und State und so, wo es eigentlich auch prinzipiell um das Funktionale und ja, also ich glaube, das ist auch der Talk, wo er anfängt, irgendwie Leute, die jetzt Erlang programmieren, die werden jetzt hier nicht viel Neues hören, weil die machen das schon richtig. Und aber jetzt für alle anderen nochmal so State und Funktion und alles so trennen, ne? Und all das halt konzeptionell auch nochmal aufgedröselt, weil, ja, ich weiß ja noch, als ich als objektorientierter Programmierer da mit Erlang angefangen hab, da war ja auch erstmal alles so, äh, Moment mal.
Wie soll ich jetzt hier programmieren?
Fnord, also das hat einfach nur so einen konstanten Fnord-Zustand erzeugt, aber wenn man es dann mal geschnallt hat und dann wieder zurück zu objektorientiert geht, dann denkt man auch so, äh, ich fühl mich schmutzig. Alles ist irgendwie im Influx, du weißt nicht, wo in dem ganzen Call-Graf irgendwie an dem Objekt noch irgendwas dran geschmuddelt wurde oder wer nicht da überall noch so seine Finger dran hatte und so, ne? Oder Variablen, genau, immer wenn ich so Code sehe, was so irgendwie Zweiseiteneffekte hat. Mein Lieblingsbeispiel in Ruby zum Beispiel, Delete auf einem Hash, sagst du, welchen Key du deleten willst, du kriegst den Value als Return, aber es löscht, also du löscht halt auch in Place, in der Variable sozusagen, den Key raus, ne? Ja, aber der Talk über Entity und so, ich weiß nicht genau, wie er heißt, findet der Chat vielleicht auch gleich nochmal raus. Der war auf jeden Fall so einfach generell ein guter Talk, um mal zu hinterfragen, wie man so objektorientiert oder auch Server-Systeme generell programmiert und mit dem State umgeht. Das eine, was wir bei WUGA auch mal im Laufe der Zeit gemacht haben, was ich wirklich ganz cool fand, war ja auch ein Stateful-Application-Service zu schreiben, wo alle anderen so HTTP und jede Session und es ist halt wie jede andere Session. Und das hat zur Folge, dass im Prinzip bei jedem Request müssen wir aus der Datenbank lesen und in die Datenbank schreiben. Und dann hat auch irgendwie ein Typ ja immer gedacht, naja Moment, aber wir haben jetzt so 5-Minuten-Sessions von diesen Schlumpfbeeren spielen. Dann können wir das auch für die Zeit vielleicht auch einfach in Memory halten und dann nur alle 30 Sekunden mal in die Datenbank geben. Und dann haben wir halt auch mit Erlang so ein Stateful-App-Server geschrieben. Und es ging einfach super leicht mit diesen Actors und so weiter. Das wäre anderweitig jetzt nicht so einfach realisierbar gewesen. Und ja, dieser Talk, der hat da auch so einige Punkte irgendwie aufgegriffen, die ich da so passiv quasi mit aufgesogen habe in dem Prozess.
Naja, im Unterschied zu Erlang ist Clojure als Sprache zum Programmieren von ganzen Systemen wesentlich weniger ausgereift. Also beides sind ja funktionale Sprachen, aber Erlang ist so an dem Ende von irgendwie die Laufzeit für immer laufende Systeme ist für dich schon gemacht. Und du kannst einfach nur deine Applikation schreiben. Und in Clojure gibt es irgendwie die tolle Sprache, in der du dich toll ausdrücken kannst. Aber wenn du deine Systeme schreiben willst damit, dann musst du dir ganz viele Sachen erst mal irgendwie selber ausdenken, mühsam zusammensuchen. Und das, was Erlang halt auszeichnet, ist eben diese ganze Laufzeitumgebung, die es dir echt ermöglicht, so lang laufende Server-Sachen zu schreiben. Das ist schon ziemlich cool.
Ja, mein erstes Erlang-Programm, das ich jemals geschrieben habe, ist so ein Push-Notification-Provider für Apple IOS Push-Notifications. Läuft seit drei Jahren am Stück ohne irgendwelche Probleme. Und das ist kein schöner Code, aber... Rock solide, genau. Machts, schubst Bits umher.
Ich erinnere, dass du damals schon gesagt hast, für jeden kleinen Scheiß muss man ja nicht unbedingt hier so eine full-blown SQL nehmen, sondern dann macht man das selber, und zwar hält man das alles im Rahmen und fertig, und dann flutscht das auch, und ist tausendmal schneller und so weiter.
Das war bei Orkut. Bei Orkut war so ein Ding. Das war so wahnsinnig schnell, und das war nur dadurch erklärbar, dass das alles im Rahmen war. Ich weiß nicht, ob du dich erinnerst. Dann konnten sie irgendwann keinen Rahmen mehr nachschneiden.
Das haben wir auch. Wir haben ein Spiel, das am meisten Geld bisher so produziert hat. Das hat ein Dataset in einem MySQL-Master von 48 GB. Dann war irgendwann die Frage, ob es schadet, oder wie auch immer. Also lass einfach 96 Gramm reinstecken in die Kiste. Und das wuppt. Das MySQL ist auf 300-400%, aber die Kiste hat auch acht Kerne.
Da hast du sonst auch was tun.
Du kannst ja auch einen Rechner für einen Terabyte RAM kaufen, heute für 10.000 Euro und fertig. Das ist ja überhaupt keine richtige Größenordnung.
Da merkt man dann auch, dass diese SQL-Datenbanken einfach auch so runteroptimiert sind, dass wenn man ihnen genug Ressourcen zur Verfügung gibt, das läuft auch einfach. Also, bis da so ein RIAC oder was auch immer, für eine Fancy Schmancy, jetzt gibt es ja Cockroach-DB, habe ich letztens gesehen.
Das gucke ich mir auch mal nicht an.
Das darfst du auch mal nicht wahrnehmen, weil es halt so resilient ist.
Ich würde meine nächste Datenbank einfach Zombie-DB nennen, aber du kannst sie vom Tod erwachen.
Ich möchte gerne Systeme schreiben, die auf einer Box laufen. Ich will gar keine verteilten Systeme. Verteilte Systeme sind nur nervig, da hat man nur Ärger mit. Es ist schlimm genug, wenn man mehrere CPUs hat, aber auf mehrere Boxen zu verteilen, was denn alle wollen und Web-Scale, Web-Scale, das will ich gar nicht, das interessiert mich nicht. Ja, vielleicht, aber ich habe immer so große Files, die ich da durchpumpen muss und Erlang ist nicht sehr ausdrucksstark. Wie ausdrucksstark? Erlang ist gut für so Message-Processing. Dafür ist das super, wenn da so kleine Messages von hier nach da und so. Ja, und viele, genau, und Volumen, aber sowas habe ich ja nicht. Ich mache ja so Data-Processing. Ja, aber ich mache es mir halt mit Clojure schön.
Du brauchst ja so eine kleine Meta-Kathedrale halt.
Ja, ich programmiere halt gerne und dann ist mir egal.
Gib mir einen Input, ich schreibe dir ein Programm für den Input.
Ich schreibe gerne Programme.
Da sollten wir vielleicht doch mal ausnahmsweise auf Apple zu sprechen kommen. Weil Apple ist ja auch der Meinung, dass man mehr poämieren sollte. Wenn auch vor allem so für ihr System. Nichtsdestotrotz, sie haben jetzt die Androhung wahrgemacht und ihre neue Poämiersprache Swift tatsächlich als Open Source Release rausgehauen. Und das auf eine Art und Weise, wie sie bisher, glaube ich, noch überhaupt keins ihrer Projekte veröffentlicht haben, was aus ihrem eigenen Kram.
Und zwar auf GitHub, komplett auf GitHub. Das war schon so das erste, was komplett faszinierend war, was das zweite war.
So wie Microsoft.
Sie haben die gesamte History reingemacht. Also du kannst dir den allerersten Commit angucken von Swift und denkst dir so, äh?
18. Juli 2010?
Der erste Commit, ne Read Me, ich frage mich, wann Apple mich wieder aus der Kamera lässt. Aber sie haben das auf der Apple-Developer-Seite steht, stand bis vor kurzem noch, Apple, the first major computer company to make open source development a key part of its software strategy. Also, first major computer company haben sie jetzt auch in wenigen, also eine halbe Stunde später stand dann da an der gleichen Stelle, Open Source Software is at the heart of Apple platforms and developer tools.
Ja, ist ja auch überhaupt, ist eine ganz neue Idee und Microsoft ist ja auch noch gar nicht auf GitHub und auch Oracle macht noch gar nicht Open Source und nein.
Naja, aber sehr mal, so Apple halt auf jeden Fall.
Ja, der nicht major, alter.
Na gut, bei Oracle musst du zugeben, die haben zwar alles auf GitHub, aber keine Programmierer mehr, die da rein programmieren. Nein, ich finde es gerade deswegen so faszinierend, weil Apple das vorher noch nie gemacht hat. Und das war so ein Schritt, den ich jetzt nicht erwartet hätte. Also es gab verschiedene Arten, Dinge Open Source zu machen. Und das war jetzt mal ein Schritt, der für Apple wirklich viel weiter ging, als alles, was sie bisher gemacht haben.
Als ihren Friedhof der Open Source-Projekte namens Mac OS Forge. Oder wie heißt das?
Alles reinpumpen und dann passiert da gar nichts.
Man muss ab und zu mal ihre Darwin-Files reindampen, weil mal wieder ein Major-Release war.
Aber eine Sache muss man schon sagen, also immerhin, sie haben ja gesagt, ein Major-Software-Companies, also Microsoft hat jetzt nicht ein Core Open Source von Windows, oder?
Das können die deswegen nicht, weil der Code ihnen nicht gehört.
Also die Aussage könnte man sogar verteidigen, es ist nur die Frage, ob es das wert ist.
Also es ist nicht komplett vollständig daneben, aber es ist auch definitiv nicht vollständig korrekt.
Ja, aber das gab es doch schon mal.
Ja, Marketing, genau.
Wir haben ja andere Sachen zu besprechen, ob es cool ist oder nicht.
Also die ganze Toolchain, die ist halt auf LLVM, ja, wunder was, ich meine, wenn der Creator von LLVM das Zeug schreibt, dann...
Der Chris Lettner ist ja auch mittlerweile, also den nur noch Creator von LLVM zu nennen, wird glaube ich seiner Rolle mittlerweile überhaupt nicht mehr gerecht. Man muss sich mal vorstellen, der ist ja mit LLVM, ist ja ja quasi bei Apple eingeschneit, weil er irgendwie mal auf der Meldungliste gefragt hat, so hier, wie ist denn das bei euch mit Objective-C? Dann sind sie irgendwie richtig auf ihn aufmerksam geworden, dann haben sie ihn einfach sofort weggecastet. Mittlerweile ist er der Chef des Complete Developments. Der Toolchain. Ich weiß nicht, ob das wirklich noch seine Bezeichnung ist.
Naja, wie auch immer der heißt.
Der ist sozusagen die entscheidende Person, die alles, was mit Code für den Computer bereitgestellt wird, das ist einfach seine Welt bei Apple. Aber sein Engagement für LLVM ist ja in dem Sinne auch nie dahinter zurückgeblieben. Es ist ja nicht so, dass er rausgekauft wurde und seine Rolle komplett feilen gelassen hätte. Ganz im Gegenteil, das Projekt ist in dem Maße ja überhaupt erst richtig aufgeblüht, weil es auch ganz andere Ressourcen hatte. Und dann ist halt der Debugger dazugekommen. Da ist dieser C-Lang.
Der hat noch nicht richtig funktioniert, aber das ist nur...
Der Debugger?
Gut, das kann ich nicht einschätzen. Ja gut, auf der Objective-C geht's, aber unter Swift funktioniert der immer noch nicht richtig.
Ja gut, aber diese Tools kamen halt dazu, Static Analyzer, und jetzt ist sozusagen Swift ist ja dann das letzte Glied, was sozusagen noch gefehlt hat.
Wir machen mal eine neue Sprache.
Ja, also jetzt haben wir irgendwie C nachprogrammiert und C++ nachprogrammiert. Und jetzt machen wir aber einfach auch nochmal eine Sprache. Ich hab ehrlich gesagt immer noch nicht so richtig... Ich hab immer noch kein Gefühl bei Swift. Also ich kann das nicht sparen.
Swift ist halt eine statisch typisierte Sprache. Und zwar sehr stark statisch typisiert, die funktionale Anteile hat, aber eine funktionale Programmiersprache ist es nicht. Und ansonsten überall Cloud, wo jemand eine gute Idee hatte. Das war mal so wirklich ganz dreist überall.
Ja gut, das muss man ja auch machen. Das muss man ja auch machen, weil sonst würde man ja versuchen, überall alles komplett neu zu machen.
Und was halt an Swift, was man sehr stark merkt, ist, dass es halt als Nachfolger für Objective-C fungieren soll und deswegen sehr viel Interoperabilität mit Objective-C bietet.
Genau. Ich wollte noch mal kurz noch was zu sagen zu diesem Open-Sourcing und wie es jetzt stattgefunden hat. Ich denke, dass sozusagen Swift ist aus der Sicht von dem Lettner nichts anderes als die anderen Sachen, die aus seinem Projekt bisher rausgekommen sind. Und es ist eigentlich vollkommen klar, dass das auch denselben Grad an Exposure und freier Lizenz etc. hat. Also es steht jetzt dem ganzen anderen Komponenten in puncto Open-Sourced-Cines nicht nach.
Ja gut, jetzt mal davon abgesehen, dass es halt ein Work in Progress ist. Das, was sie jetzt veröffentlicht haben, kann man so, wie es ist, überhaupt gar nicht benutzen. Also gut, die Compiler-Linker, die Bagger funktionieren, aber der Rest ist nicht nutzbar, sinnvoll, weil es ist mitten Work in Progress. Also das Ding ist, was sie da veröffentlicht haben, und das war für mich die große Überraschung, war ja nicht nur, wir machen jetzt eine Toolchain für die Sprache, sondern sie haben halt die Standard-Bibliothek von Swift mit veröffentlicht. Okay, die existiert, die kann man benutzen, aber was sie halt gleichzeitig machen, sie wollen Foundation, also quasi einen unteren Teil des Coco-Frameworks, komplett neu schreiben in Swift, beziehungsweise der untere Teil von Foundation ist ja sowieso immer in C geschrieben gewesen und immer Open Source, aber es hatte immer ein Objective-C-Layer obendrauf, so als Interface, damit man es auch benutzen kann. Und diesen Interface-Layer wollen sie komplett in Swift umschreiben, so dass Foundation hinterher so eine Art Swift-only...
Aber Foundation bleibt immer noch in C, oder was?
Ja, Core Foundation, wie es so schön heißt, ist in C.
Ja, und wird es auch in C bleiben?
Ja, natürlich. Ich meine, das ist alte Next-Technologie. Das Zeug ist abgehangen, das funktioniert und es ist schnell. Also es gibt keinen Grund, das jetzt in Swift umzuschreiben. Das werden sie vielleicht irgendwann tun, aber...
Außer zu zeigen, dass sie es können. Ja, dass es vielleicht auch irgendwelche Vorteile hat gegen C. Ich finde das immer so verdächtig, wenn irgendwelche untersten Teile einer Poemiersprache in einer anderen Poemiersprache geschrieben sind, als in sich selbst. Find ich.
Ja gut, aber da kannst du dann auch zu Erlang zeigen oder zu anderen.
Oder Ruby oder allen möglichen anderen Sprachen.
Ganz unten ist es immer in C geschrieben, irgendwie. Also, ja gut, Pascal vielleicht nicht.
Common List ist auch meistens in Common List.
Aber es gibt halt nicht... Also es gibt sehr viele andere Sprachen, die halt immer so in C können haben. Es gibt natürlich die Ausnahmen, aber es ist nicht die Wege.
Aber wie gesagt, die Standard Library ist tatsächlich in Swift geschrieben.
Kann ich mal einen ganz, ganz kurzen Non-Maskable-Interrupt reinschmeißen? Haben wir eigentlich auch Schokolade bekommen? Als Teil unserer Geschwährung?
Das klappt zuletzt vor allem Studentenfutter, weil das hatte ich eigentlich gesagt.
Studentenfutter ist auch sehr schick, nehme ich auch gerne.
Ich glaube, da ist sogar noch Schokolade.
Bringst du noch einen O-Saft mit? Was sie halt noch mit drin haben, ist Libdispatch. Das ist ja auch schon länger open source, aber das hat nie unter Linux funktioniert. Und einer der erklärten Ziele von diesem open source Port ist, dass sie es tatsächlich auch unter Linux zum Laufen kriegen und das dann ganz normal unter Linux benutzbar ist. Keine Ahnung, wie weit das passiert.
Libdispatch ist ihr Parallelisierungs-Prozesse, Asynchroneprozesse-Tool, wobei sie ja auch angedeutet haben, dass sie diese ganze Gleichzeitigkeit auch noch in die Sprache mit reinbringen wollen, irgendwann mal, aber noch nicht in der nächsten Version.
Ja, da habe ich aber noch nichts von gelesen. Also da muss ich noch mal eine Runde drüber nachdenken.
Sie haben angekündigt, dass sie das noch nicht in Version 3 machen, so war die Formulierung.
Ja, und dann halt Exitest, also das ganze Test-Framework, das sie in Xcode eingebaut haben, das soll es irgendwie auch schaffen. Das ist ja auch sehr stark auf Objective-C noch basiert, weil Objective-C ja halt eine dynamischere Sprache ist. Da kannst du halt sagen, hey, hallo, klasse, wie heißen denn alle deine Funktionen? Ja, okay, ruf sie mal alle hintereinander auf. Das kannst du halt in Swift jetzt so nicht machen. Keine Ahnung, wie Exit-Test dann unter Swift funktionieren wird. Vielleicht bauen sie doch noch ein bisschen Dynamik ein. Aber alles, was dahinter steckt, ist, sie wollen komplett das Objective-C rauskriegen aus allem, was man braucht, um sinnvolle Software zu machen, weil sie nicht Objective-C auch noch nach Linux portieren wollen. Sondern alles, was auf Linux läuft, ist nur Swift und kein Objective-C fertig. Dazu portieren sie eben diese drei Sachen so, dass sie unter Swift benutzbar sind.
Diese Foundation und so, die ganzen Strings, die ganzen Klassen, das ist alles als Code in dem GitHub mit drin?
Ja, teilweise.
Da feuern die als Code, oder die Foundation?
Nee, nur den C-Unterteil. Vor allen Dingen von den Container-Klassen, so Array, Dictionary und so weiter.
Das gibt's jetzt alles in Swift-Code?
Ziel ist, dass dann Swift 3 mit dem fertigen Foundation mal rauskommt, aber ich glaube, vor einem dreiviertel Jahr wird das keine Gestalt annehmen.
Also noch ist die Foundation nicht in GitHub?
Doch, die Foundation ist in GitHub, aber viele Objekte sind relativ leer. Also viele Klassen. Also es ist wirklich ongoing work. Also das ist, ja.
Ich verstehe. Kommt also noch.
Genau.
Da sind auch schon 60 oder so.
Ja, die haben schon relativ viel. Ich weiß auch schon benutzt.
Weiß nicht, ob das von App intern ist oder extern.
Was ich auch relativ spannend fand, war den Package-Manager, den sie gleich mit angekündigt haben. So nach der Art, du hast eine Open Source Package, das ist ja toll. Da bauen wir jetzt ein System, wie du deine Abhängigkeit von Open Source Packages irgendwie managen kannst, indem sie gleich in Swift einen Package-Manager schreiben, der als Beschreibungssprache auch noch Swift verwendet. Gut, ob das jetzt sinnvoll ist? Hm, weiß man nicht.
Natürlich ist das sinnvoll.
Aber sinnvoll ist natürlich, dass das Bildsystem und der Package-Manager aus einer Hand kommen, damit die relativ gut zusammenarbeiten können. Also der Package-Manager, da sieht man noch so gut wie gar nichts. Da gibt es nur ein großes Pfeil, was sie sich alles vorstellen, was sie in der ersten Version haben wollen. Also das ist so...
Chris Letten hat auch die meisten Commits bei dem Swift. Naja, wie Hans das schon kennt, wenn man erstmal so Projektleiter ist, dann ist nichts mehr mit Code. Du hattest das, glaube ich, irgendwo mal, wo du auch meintest, du kommst nicht mehr zum Spaß haben. Und...
Ja, aber ich denke, dass er auch wirklich derjenige ist, der sich das im Wesentlichen alles ausgedacht hat. Und dass da einfach seine komplette Erfahrung des Compilerbaus auf der einen Seite und auch dieser ganzen... Was kann man einfach... Also, was muss eine Sprache haben oder nicht haben, damit man sie wirklich schnell macht. Ich glaube, das ist das Spannende, auch aus meiner Perspektive jetzt. Dass die Sprache vielleicht nicht unbedingt jetzt die Sexiness hat am Ende, die ich irgendwie geil finde. Aber dass sie vielleicht, was so rohe Performance betrifft, durchaus einen Punkt hat, weil schneller geworden ist, ist ja wohl schon.
Also, was ich ehrlich gesagt am abgefahrensten fand, waren die Proposals für Swift 3. Unter anderem den Vorschlag, den C-Style-4-Loop mit diesen drei Argumenten mal aus der Sprache zu nehmen. Und das andere, den Increment- und Decrement-Operator aus der Sprache zu nehmen.
Was ist daran jetzt böse, laut aktueller religiöser Rechtsprecher?
Also das erste ist, der C-Style-4-Loop-Konstruktor.
Ja, der war immer hässlich.
War immer hässlich, wird eigentlich nicht verwendet.
Decrement, Decrement.
Wird auch nicht verwendet.
Es kommt selten hin.
Wir streiben über Tippen wieder, bla, gleich, bla, plus.
Na ja, na i plus plus kann es halt dann auch in der Regel schon mit irgendwie...
i.advance, Klammer auf, Klammer zu, wow, top.
Nein, das Ding ist, dass du auf vielen Datenstrukturen ja keinen Index hast, sondern einen Iterator. Und du den Iterator dann advanced und nicht deinen Index. Und die dadurch, dass du keinen Index hast, schneller sind, weil du dann nicht über den Index an die Objekte rangehen musst, wenn du die sowieso nur in einer Reihe iterieren willst.
Wie kann ich mein integer hochzählen? I plus gleich 1.
Das ist sozusagen genau zwei Zeichen mehr. Und da meinen sie, das wäre jetzt auch nicht so...
Aber plus gleich lassen wir noch übrig.
Ja, das bleibt drin.
Da gucken jetzt die Funktionalen-Programmierer gleich wieder so ein bisschen mitleidig.
Ja, da sind noch ein paar andere abgefahrenere Proposals drin. Aber das waren so die beiden, die ich bemerkenswert fand, weil sie irgendwie so... Ja, jetzt wollen wir noch ein bisschen mehr C-Baggage, was wir einfach so übernommen haben, loswerden. Das finde ich schon relativ gut.
Also es ist halt die gleiche Read-Freitsprache irgendwie.
Naja, aber man merkt... Also da sind noch andere Proposals, die sich damit beschäftigen. Man merkt, dass der Push weg von den Variablen hin zu den Single-Assignment-Konstrukten da ist in Swift, ganz stark. Also ich möchte nicht sagen, Push in die funktionale Ecke, aber diese ganze... Es ist alles Variabel-Ding, das will man eigentlich nicht mehr haben.
Keine Programmierung... Hans, ich weiß nicht, ob du das unterschreiben würdest, aber mein Eindruck ist ja, alle Programmierungsprachen die letzten 20 Jahre rauskamen. Nachdem sie rauskam, waren sie dann die nächsten 20 Jahre erstmal damit beschäftigt. Alle Features von Lisp einzubauen, die sie zu dem Zeitpunkt noch nicht vorgesehen hatten, da hätte man auch eigentlich gleich der ganze Run auf Closures und was nicht alles. So, ja, ne, jetzt sind wir auch total modern, jetzt kennen wir das auch.
Ja, aber es ist andererseits so, dass Lisp auch nicht alles hat, was andere Sprachen haben. Insofern, es stimmt in Grenzen, aber es ist so die typische Smug-Lisp-Weenie-Haltung. Macht ihr doch, macht ihr doch, ich hab ja alles. Ich brauch nicht mehr. Ihr kommt ja sowieso da an, wo ich jetzt schon bin.
Ein Kollege hat mir erzählt, dass sein erster Job war in einer Smalltalk-Konsultant-Bude in Aachen oder so. Er war halt nur Intern und er war auch als Java-Code, aber sie wollten sich so ein bisschen breiter aufstellen. Er war der erste und bis dato einzige Java-Code und alle anderen Smalltalk-Konsultants, die vier Tage die Woche in die ganze Welt geflogen sind. Am Freitag waren sie alle im Büro und haben ihn dann rundum gehänselt. Dann haben sie sich auch in ihrer kleinen Nische ganz stark gefühlt. Er ist nicht lange geblieben, meinte er. Das war zwar auch in Teilen lustig, aber...
Du googlest gerade Swiftly, da musst du im iTunes-Store gucken. Das ist nämlich eine App, mit der man irgendwie Swift lernen kann. Ich habe mir die mal angeguckt und war jetzt nicht so geflasht.
Für iOS?
Ja, für iOS. Das liegt aber, glaube ich, im großen Teil daran, dass sie wirklich bei Adam und Eva und dem Apfel anfangen. Jeder, der vorher schon mal einen Compiler oder einen Interpreter in der Hand hatte, ist vielleicht ein bisschen unterfordert von dem Ding. Keine Ahnung, wie weit das dann noch geht, aber ich hatte so das Gefühl, die ersten 20 Seiten von dem Swift... Also ich meine, man kann sich das Ding runterladen und kann so lange machen, wie es um ist, und sich dann überlegen, ob man die Chapters haben will. Aber mich hat das jetzt nicht so vom Hocker gerissen. Insgesamt.
Es wendet sich nicht an dich.
Nee, ich bin nicht Zielgruppe. Ich bin nicht Zielgruppe, aber keine Ahnung. Ich bin halt auch immer... Ich bin halt auch schon am Typsystem gescheitert, weil manche Dinge mit Protokollen nicht zu machen sind, weil Protokollerweiterung von einer Protokollerweiterung von einem Typ und so weiter. Das ging dann irgendwie nicht, und ich hab's nicht verstanden, worum's nicht geht.
Ich muss sagen, echt so... Ich hab ja jetzt auch nicht so viele Sprachen gelernt, aber dieses Learn-You-A-Haskell war ja, glaube ich, so das erste, was rauskam, und dann kam ja der andere Typ mit Learn-You-Some-Earlang. Die beiden Sachen, die fand ich ja total super, weil erstens stand da alles drin und eigentlich auch viel mehr als in den, sag mal, O'Reilly oder was auch immer Büchern, weil die halt einfach von Leuten, die damit sich richtig auseinandergesetzt haben, geschrieben waren. Und du konntest halt auch dadurch, dass es alles gab, auch einfach so die Teile überspringen, die dich jetzt wirklich nicht mehr interessiert haben. Und Learn-You-Some-Earlang, ja, das... Also als ich Erlang gelernt hab, war das wirklich meine Primärquelle, weil die Bücher, die es zu der Zeit gab, die waren halt auch schon irgendwie... Also das von Joe Armstrong von O'Reilly, das muss man zum Beispiel, oder nee, von Pragmatic Programmer, das muss man nicht lesen. Also das ist wirklich... Da sind mir die Augen direkt schon auf den ersten zehn Seiten. Also das Konzept von der Sprache mal zu erklären, das ist erstmal super, aber den Rest des Buchs, also der Joe, der hat schon was geleistet und so, aber...
Besonders durch die Augen.
Er ist kein besonders großer... Ja, oder Lehrer oder guter... Didakt, ja. Das kann man wohl schon sagen. Und dieser Fred Hebert, oder wie er immer heißt, der hat da echt...
Vor allen Dingen seine Zeichnungen immer.
Ja, die sind auch wirklich großartig. Also da ist echt viel Liebe reingegangen. Also da hat er wirklich was richtig Gutes für die Erlangen Community geleistet, muss man schon echt sagen. Und dieses Learn Your Haskell, das ist ja ähnlich gut. Ich bin da zwar nie so weit gekommen, weil dann irgendwie bin ich bei diesem Haskell dann doch ein bisschen ausgestiegen, weil...
Ich fand die Syntax irgendwann nicht mehr erträglich bei Haskell, aber...
Bei mir war das eher so, okay, ihr wollt jetzt wirklich das mit den Seiteneffekten so lange wie möglich rauszögern, na gut. Aber irgendwann wollen wir doch mal irgendwie Input und Output haben. Also wie ist es denn jetzt?
Es gibt Probleme, da braucht man eben halt auch In-Place-Dinge, die sie dir ersetzt werden. Sonst wirst du nicht mehr fertig.
Ja, ich finde ja, bei Erlang haben sie irgendwie so einen galanten Shortcut genommen, um mit ihren Seiteneffekten da klarzukommen. Aber bei Haskell, also es ist trotzdem auf jeden Fall wert da mal reinzulesen, weil auch da gehen so ein paar Glühbirnchen zwischendurch mal an. Das ist halt so für so dunkle Winterabende, wenn man sonst nichts zu tun hat, kann man da schon mal ein bisschen rumspielen. Ja, ja, Head und Tail, genau. Die ganzen tollen Sachen.
So, noch ein Nachtrag zu Swift? Was denkst du, wie es abfliegen wird? Wann werden alle nur noch in Swift programmiert?
Also ich kann dir sagen, bei Vuga würde jetzt kein iOS-Programmierer noch Objective-C koden. Die sind jetzt alle schon total offen.
Also es ist halt so, du hast halt so eine Legacy-Code-Base von, weiß ich nicht wie viel, je nach Projekt zwischen 300 und 500 Klassen, Objective-C. Und dann kommt Swift und dann ist es so, dass die ganzen leckeren Features der Sprache kannst du nicht verwenden, wenn du irgendwie das mit Objective-C zusammen benutzen musst und dann willst du eigentlich alles hinschmeißen und etwas ganz Neues schreiben. Aber wenn man jetzt anfängt, das zu mischen, was wir gerade angefangen haben, dann ist es immer so ein bisschen schwierig. Also es geht zwar alles irgendwie, aber dann muss man sich auf der einen Seite zurückhalten, dann muss man sich auf der anderen Seite zurückhalten. Es ist so ein bisschen so, mal gucken.
Am besten, wenn man frisch anfangen kann natürlich.
Also es geht erstaunlich gut dafür, dass du halt irgendwie eine Objective-C-Klasse von Swift aus ableiten kannst und extenden kannst und hast sie nicht gesehen. Und dann machst du einen I-Namen in Swift und benutzt es in Objective-C und solche Sachen. Also das ist schon, da hat Apple viel geleistet, aber am Ende des Tages willst du den Code nicht mischen, sondern willst halt frisch anfangen.
Ja, das ist auch so ein bisschen meine Befürchtung, dass vielleicht, das kann ich jetzt an gar nichts belegen, das ist nur so ein Gefühl. Ich meine, ist ja klar, dass sie diese Sprache in ihrem Ökosystem nicht so ohne Weiteres durchgedrückt bekommen, wenn sie diese Interoperabilität nicht haben.
Man merkt es auch, seit Swift rausgekommen ist, haben sie in Objective-C schon zwei, drei Sachen nachgerüstet, nur damit es besser interoperabel ist. Und wenn die das weiter so machen, dann ist das Objective-C in zwei Jahren an dem Punkt, wo man sagt, warum haben die jetzt eigentlich Swift gemacht?
Ja, gut, ich meine, das wäre ja dann noch ganz gut. Ich hatte jetzt nur so mehr die Befürchtung, dass das gesamte Design von Swift unter Umständen einfach bestimmte Schritte nie gegangen ist, weil sie wissen, dass sie da nicht hingehen können, ohne sich nicht ihre Kompatibilität mit ihrem alten Scheiß zu verbauen. Und von daher auch nicht so gut ist, wie es sein könnte.
Na ja, gut, man kann natürlich immer jetzt darüber diskutieren, versucht man einen Ansatz zu machen, der halt so multiparadigmamäßig ist? Oder ist es jetzt nur auf Biegen und Brechen Kompatibilität zum Alten? Also, Swift ist halt eine Sprache, die bietet Klassen und Strukturen. Es ist keine pure, funktionale Sprache.
Aber das sind ja die... Also, die reine Lehre, die gibt es ja eh nirgends.
Ja, nun, ja, aber es gibt reinere Lehren, als das Swift ist. Also, und Swift versucht viel von diesem, wir bauen hier irrsinnig viel State auf und handeln den überall wegzukommen. Also, fast überall wird man immer in die Richtung gestupst. Das ist jetzt aber konstant. Und das ist jetzt auch konstant. Und das ist jetzt auch konstant. Und das ist schon die richtige Richtung. Aber das geht halt nicht über Nacht.
Also, es ist ein hübsch gecamter Hund, aber er pisst trotzdem noch an Laternen.
Ja, aber er fragt vorher nochmal nach.
Aber ich muss ja echt sagen, wenn es um die reine Lehre geht, ich finde ja nach wie vor, also reine Lehre kann ja auch sein, einfach Konsequenzen und Filmen durchziehen. Und ich finde ja nach wie vor, auch wenn ich jetzt nicht mehr für Ruby programmiere, aber ich finde einfach die Sprache auch immer noch geil, weil die einfach so konsequent Freestyle ist und wirklich alles ein Objekt ist und selbst Operatoren und Methoden auf der Masterclass sind und alles überladbar und alles zur Laufzeit aufreißbar und änderbar und die Sprache geht dir so maximal aus dem Weg. Du kannst alles machen.
Hab ich schon mal gehört, ist das nicht so Perl-mäßig?
Ja, nee, es ist deutlich, deutlich...
More than one way to do it...
.deutlich liestbarer als Perl und deutlich schicker als Perl.
Ja, wenn jeder es auch so machen kann.
Sonst rede ich hier noch mit und das willst du nicht.
Ah ja, also ich hab mit Perl tatsächlich angefangen zu programmieren. Jetzt kommt's raus. Aber der Yuki Hiro Matsumoto, der sich Ruby ausgedacht hat, der hat ja auch ganz schlafe Perl-Einflüsse in Ruby. Also du kriegst auch deine ganzen Perl-Special-Variablen in Ruby. Also Dollar hast du nicht gesehen und Dollar Schrägstrich und so. Das hat er tatsächlich auch sich nicht verkneifen können mit einzubauen. Er hat ja so einen Blend aus seinen Lieblingssprachen gemacht. Eine davon war Smalltalk, eine davon war Perl und dann sind noch zwei, drei andere.
Lispia angeblich auch.
Ja, aber ich glaube, das sieht man nur, da muss man dann wirklich ganz genau hingucken.
Aber bei Ruby ist es auf alle Fälle so, dass die Leute, die es mal gelernt haben und mal darin viel programmiert haben, die vergöttern das. Das ist noch schlimmer, als wir Perl-Programmierer.
Ja, ich glaube, es kommt so mit Smalltalk, dann kommt es auch so ein bisschen in die gleiche Richtung. Aber wie gesagt, mittlerweile fühle ich mich schmutzig, wenn ich objektorientiert programmiere, aber trotzdem macht die Sprache Spaß, wenn man eben mal irgendein Problem lösen muss, weil die einem so voll aus dem Weg geht und nirgendswo dir so hier irgendwie reingrätscht noch mal von der Seite und denkst, ah, welcher, so wie JavaScript zum Beispiel. Ich stelle mich schon mal hin für den Endspurt hier, ich gehe schon mal ein bisschen in die Knie.
Jetzt ist auch noch unser Stream ausgefallen.
Ach, der liebe Zeit.
Und das wäre jetzt eine Bingo-Karte gewesen, aber das kann keiner hören.
Ich schreibe es einfach in den Chat.
Der Chat hat es schon gemerkt, und ich habe es auch gerade gemerkt. Und irgendwie kann ich mich gerade bei Sinem nicht einloggen. Ah, jetzt ist er wieder. Ne, Login failed irgendwie. Aber ich denke, wir können jetzt ohnehin die Sendung zu Ende bringen.
Trotz des Dinges muss ich ihn ja reinschieben, weil ich es nur noch angedroht habe. Und jetzt Leute darauf warten. Ja, ich mach das doch nicht wieder, aber aus technischem Grund. Diese Nummer mit dem 8021X von der Telekom, fahre ich doch gestern durch die Stadt. Wenigst der nichts sagt mein Telefon zu mir. Pling, Moment, lese ich original vor. Kriege ich eine Kurzmitteilung von der beliebten und bekannten deutschen Telekom, die mir doch schreibt, und zwar ohne, dass ich irgendetwas gemacht habe mit meinem Telefon. Also nicht aktiv irgendwas angewählt oder Hotspots angewählt oder so. Die schreibt mir willkommen am Hotspot der Telekom. Sie sind via Telekom unterstrich SIM über WLAN mit dem Internet verbunden und nutzen ihre Hotspot-Flat. Es fallen keine zusätzlichen Kosten an. Und ich dachte mir, Moment mal, nach Tegallik, wo der Trapsen erst mal Auto geparkt, so Dinky sucht, der hängt dieser Hotspot, der Telekom, der das macht. Es gibt inzwischen mehrere davon, das haben andere Leute mir auch schon getwittert, und Potsdamer Hauptbahnhof hängt einer, der sowas schon kann. Der von dem Eckrede, der steckt mitten in der Stadt, Wilhelmstraße, Ecke Leipziger Straße, da bei Göring unter dem Schreibtisch, äh, bei Schäuble. Also neuer Finanzminister, neuer Alter, wie auch immer. Und der Gag daran ist, dass sich der Telefon dort einfach einbucht und dass kein Portal weit und breit ist. Also nicht irgendeine Drecksportalseite hochpoppt und mit tippen sie hier ihre Kennungen ein und klicken sie Ja für Okay und akzeptieren sie und La. Sondern der Ding bucht sich dort einfach ein und man hat dort Internet. Einfach so, so wie man sich das eigentlich immer vorgestellt hat. Nein. Da bucht sich ja das Telefon nicht freiwillig ein. Weil die auch alle anders heißen. Der Hintergrund dahinter ist, das war nämlich ein Punkt, deswegen spreche ich so an, ich hatte das in diesem Sommer glaube ich schon mal erwähnt in der Freak Show, weil da in meinem so geliebten Reiseland Schweden ja die Tele ja schon länger macht, dass die Telekom jetzt Hotspots mit diesem 8021X Feature aufsetzt oder auch WPA Enterprise Feature, wo sich das Telefon selber mit seiner SIM-Karte, mit den Daten, also von der SIM-Karte und auch der Kryptomechanik auf der SIM-Karte einloggt ins Telekom Netz. Das heißt also die ganze Authentication und welcher User ist es und wem müssen wir das SEK auf den Hals schicken, wenn er da Kinder, Nazi, Surf, Childporn macht und so. Das ist alles schon eingebaut, das ist alles schon fertig. Und das finde ich jetzt einfach mal eine sehr interessante Erfahrung. Da könnte man sich jetzt noch länger darüber auslassen, wie das funktioniert, aber die Zeit haben wir heute nicht. Aber wie gesagt, wir kommen da so langsam hin. Ich hoffe mal, dass das...
Das ist aber dann nur für Telekom-Leute, weil deine SIM-Daten zur Authentifizierung benutzt werden.
Technisch gesehen ginge das. Aber es gibt wahrscheinlich wieder keinen Abrechnungsmodus.
Okay, also die machen das aber für ihre eigenen Kunden.
Sie machen es primär für ihre eigenen Kunden. Man könnte das auch so machen, dass jetzt vielleicht auch einer für mehrere Netzbetreiber macht. Das ist durchaus auch denkbar, dass vielleicht, wenn ein O2 oder ein E-Plus oder so mal auf die Idee kommt, dass sie das sozusagen für ihre Leute machen. Oder es könnte zum Beispiel auch sein, das weiß ich gar nicht, ob die Telekom gibt es ja nicht nur in Deutschland. Ob die Telekom zum Beispiel auch ihre ausländischen Kunden, also die ausländischen Kunden aus ihren anderen Netzen, die sie so hat auf der Welt, da auch mitspielen lässt. Aber das ist immerhin schon mal ein interessanter Schritt. Es lässt auch so ein bisschen klingeln so in Richtung, wir telefonieren jetzt mal über Wi-Fi, wie das ja so schön heißt, was ja in den USA jetzt auch der neueste heiße Scheiß ist, dass die Netzbetreiber eben den Leuten sagen, ja du kannst dein Telefon ganz normal in irgendeinem WLAN betreiben. Und dich darüber einbuchen in unser Netz. Das heißt also deine ganzen normalen Telefonfunktionen gehen dann halt einfach auch da, wo wir jetzt gerade keinen Netzpunkt haben, sondern halt in irgendeinem WLAN. Dieses sogenannte Wi-Fi-Calling, was Apple ja auch schon ein paar Mal angedroht hat, was mit AT&T, glaube ich, zum Beispiel schon machen oder so, über Comcast. Und das ist denke ich auch ein Vorbote davon, für das, was da in Deutschland passiert. Deswegen ist das also doppelt spannend. Also erstens mal wie gesagt ein Hotspot-Zugang, der ja nicht nervt. Und zweitens halt eben auch so ein bisschen, man hört ja so langsam so ein bisschen die Zukunft mal hinten mal klingeln. Würde mich freuen, wenn es da noch Leute gibt, die noch mehr von diesem Telekom-SIM-Hotspot finden irgendwo, wenn man mal herausfinden würde, wo die jetzt sind. Weil es sind nicht alle Telekom-Hotspots. Ich bin ja gestern da auch noch ein bisschen rumgelaufen. Zum Beispiel auch da ist ja dann gleich...
Aber er schickt einem dann so eine Message.
Das macht er nur beim ersten Mal. Ich bin heute wieder dran vorbei gefahren, das macht er nicht mehr. Immerhin, also sie sagen das auch, die buchen dich da nicht einfach nur ein und klauen dir sozusagen die Bits weg oder wie auch immer. Also klauen sie ja nicht weg, sondern buchst dich halt ein, nutzt das Netz. Aber sie sagen auch, ja, hallo, hier bist du jetzt bei uns in dem W-Laden drin und keine Sorgen, das kostet dich nichts. Das funktioniert aber nur für Leute, die auch eine Hotspot-Flat haben. Wenn du also wieder einen Tarif hast, der keine Hotspot-Flat hast, dann... Womit wir da bei dem Thema sind, was Hans von hatte, dass halt eben die Technik ist da, aber die Tarife riechen halt aus dem Mund. Dein Thema, wo du sagst, man müsste mal LTE regulieren, fällt in das gleiche Ding. Die Technik ist geil. LTE kann man echt nicht maulen. Das hat ordentlich Bums und schnell und breit verfügbar und so, aber das kann sich halt keine Sau leisten. Jedenfalls nicht hier. In anderen Ländern, eigentlich fast überall.
Außer hier.
Und in den USA. Das ist immer ganz toll. Die Amis sind immer ganz hinten im Halm. Wenn meine Ami-Kollegen von ITF oder so hier mal auftauchen, die sind immer so erstaunt, wie billig das hier in Deutschland ist, und ich so, you ain't seen nothing yet. Also, komm, lass mal nach Österreich, Italien oder Finnland fahren oder so. Aber ja, die leiden echt da noch am schwersten mit drunter auch. Ja, das ist der freie Markt halt. Aber keine Sorge, das hält ihr nicht mehr lange, weil Herr Trump hat ja entdeckt, dass das eine super Idee ist, das Internet zuzumachen.
Ja, das soll, das soll Bill Gates bewirken, dass das Markt gescheit wird.
Da müssen wir jetzt wirklich nicht mehr drüber brechen, Leute.
Nee, lass uns mal Schluss machen, ich bin auch müde.
Ich hab das so am Rande mitgekriegt und dachte auch so, oh man, the idiots are taking over, we know if it's just for yarn.
Es ist übrigens ein interessantes Gedankenspiel, was man mal machen kann, sich zu überlegen, was dann eigentlich passieren würde.
Das machen wir offline jetzt gleich.
Unser Astrim ist ja eh schon gestorben, von daher fühlen wir das jetzt hier sozusagen auch schon mal vor.
Ja, liebe Nachhöre, es tut uns leid.
Genau, aber ihr habt ja gemerkt, der letzte Teil war jetzt auch nicht mehr...
Sagen wir mal, da unten leuchtet, das geht Richtung Xenim, oder was?
Das war's?
Das war da unten da.
Das ist mein Trace-Route und der sagt halt, dass hier irgendwie komische IP-Adressen gelten, die hier eigentlich ganz anders stehen. Und ich weiß nicht genau, was das bedeutet.
Ich weiß, was das bedeutet. Wo trägst du eigentlich hin? Was ist dein Ziel? Das wird uns interessant, weil er nämlich bei Hetzner ist und wir hier im Telekom-Netz sind. Bei der Frage, hat denn Xenim die 5 Euro bei Hetzner bezahlt, dass das jetzt ordentlich wucken kann? Nächste Frage.
Da war sie wieder, die Regulierung.
Hans, vielen Dank fürs Kommen.
Für das Speis und Trank.
Und war nicht zu langweilig, hoffen wir.
Also bei Apple bin ich dann halt raus.
Aber bei uns bist du immer dabei. So, wir sagen Tschüss, bis bald. Wir sehen uns auf dem Kongress oder auch nicht. Und ansonsten dann wieder im Januar. Also noch eine Sendung Gips vom Kongress. Und danach ist 2016.